Hallo, hallo, wer ist da so alles am Start? Schon der Feuer ist wieder da.
Ah, du bist aber auch immer schneller am Start.
Der Stream ist 20 Sekunden on und du warst vor 20 Sekunden, du warst instant da.
Ich glaube immer noch, dass du irgendeinen Bot hast für sowas.
So schnell kann es doch gar nicht sein normalerweise.
Chatgear, Pfeiffer Chatgear.
Wie lange war ich das letzte Mal eigentlich on?
Schon ein bisschen her, oder?
War ich denn das letzte Mal on?
Oh, 5 Tagen, guck mal, so lange ist das schon her.
Bin ich in 5 Spieljahren auch am Start?
Ne, gar nicht mal so sehr.
Auch abends immer mal so ein bisschen, aber nicht so krass.
Ja, bei mir ist es auch übelst warm.
Aber ich habe ja das Glück, ich habe eine Klimaanlage.
Will der Igel, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe zum Glück eine Klimaanlage.
Lorsum Alpha, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, Klimaanlage ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Ich werde mal die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Deine Klimaanlage läuft den ganzen Tag durch.
Naja, das ist ja auch nicht so schlimm.
Wenn du es nicht zu kalt eingestellt hast, kühlt die ja nicht unbedingt permanent und verbraucht mega viel Strom.
Es ist wahrscheinlich...
Es ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser, wie man stellt die zu kalt ein und dann macht man zwischendurch immer wieder aus und dann wieder runter.
Die regeln das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hatte jetzt auch 2 Stunden oder so die Klimaanlage laufen.
Habe jetzt eine halbe Stunde wieder aus.
Aber ich bin halt blöd, ich habe die Tür zum Flur hin aufgelassen.
Das heißt, es ist wieder alles warm.
Aber ich muss mal...
Ich schaue mal kurz...
Moment, lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Home Assistant, Arbeitszimmer...
Im Serverraum ist 30 Grad, Leute.
30,2 Grad.
30,2 Grad im Serverraum.
Ordentlich.
Naja, gut.
Ich meine...
Hey.
Es ist nicht nur im professionellen Rechenzentrum der Trend,
dass man es ein bisschen wärmer werden lässt im Vergleich zu früher.
Warum nicht auch bei mir im Kabuff?
Ja, hier bei mir im Zimmer ist es ja so zwischen 26 und 27 Grad.
Ich war blöd und habe das nicht eingestellt, dass ich das hinterm Komma sehe.
Ich denke mal so 26,8 oder irgendwie sowas.
Weil vorhin war es 27,4 als ich die Klimaanlage angeschmissen habe.
Also, ich muss echt sagen, das hat sich wirklich gelohnt mit der Klimaanlage.
Ich habe die Klimaanlage vor...
Das war vor Corona noch.
Also sprich...
Ja, ich denke mal so fünf Jahre müsste ich die wahrscheinlich sogar schon haben.
Ich habe dazu garantiert damals was auf Twitter geschrieben, aber...
Twitter ist ja nicht mehr richtig durchsuchbar.
Twitter ist ja nicht mehr benutzbar.
Richtig gescheit.
Ich habe übrigens auch gesagt, dass ich die Klimaanlage nicht mehr benutzen kann.
Ich habe auch gesagt, dass ich die Klimaanlage nicht mehr benutzen kann.
Ich habe auch gelesen, dass Twitter jetzt irgendwie den Blog-Button oder so entfernen möchte.
Das wird sicherlich ganz viele Leute abfacken, die instant irgendwie immer alle Leute blocken.
Ich habe nicht so viele Leute geblockt auf Twitter, muss ich sagen.
Vielleicht über die ganzen Jahre, lass es mal 20 Leute sein oder so.
Nicht, wirklich nicht viel insgesamt.
Also, muss mir schon echt auf den Sack gehen, oft wenn ich Leute blogge.
Es gibt ja Leute, die haben so...
Kennt ihr das?
Das finde ich ein mega bescheuerter Trend.
Den es auch schon so ein paar Jahre gibt.
Es gibt so Bubble-Blog-Listen.
Also, wenn du jetzt irgendwie denkst, ah, ich bin der krasse, was weiß ich, Woke-Typ oder so.
Und dann kannst du quasi die irgendeine Blog-List suchen und da sind dann Leute drauf, die von anderen, die so deine Gesinnung und Meinung teilen, gemeldet haben.
Und dann kannst du quasi instant irgendwie 3000 Leute blocken.
Obwohl du gar nicht weißt, wer das ist und was...
Also, total wir, ja.
Also, es gibt Leute, die blocken halb Twitter gefühlt per automatischer Blog-Liste.
Keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Ja, das habe ich gelesen, das habe ich gelesen.
Aber, ganz ehrlich, ich bin da mittlerweile vorsichtig geworden.
Ich dachte am Anfang auch, dass einige Änderungen so auf Twitter gar nicht mal so blöd gewesen sind.
Aber, ich bin da mittlerweile vorsichtig geworden.
Aber, die letzten paar Wochen kamen Sachen, die ich fast, durch die ich Twitter fast als kaum noch richtig benutze.
Ich habe auch gar nicht mehr richtig Bock, Twitter zu benutzen.
Kaum als richtig benutzbar.
Also, der Login-Zwang ist mega für den Arsch.
Ja, man kann wohl, wenn man auf Tweets referenziert, was ja viele News-Seiten machen.
Ja, und die Umbenennung in den X finde ich auch hängen geblieben.
Tweets verlinkt auf News-Seiten geht das, sieht man aber keine Antworten mehr und sowas.
Also, Login-Zwang ist bescheuert.
Und es ist...
Es ist...
Einiges.
Auch, dass die Suche nicht mal funktioniert, gescheit.
Und wenn du nicht eingeloggt noch wo drauf gehst, wenn es überhaupt geht, dann ist es nicht sortiert und sowas.
Ganz, ganz furchtbar merkwürdig.
Vielleicht die Umbenennung in X finde ich auch ultra bescheuert.
Also, ich...
Ja, zum Beispiel...
Zum Beispiel das mit den Haken und so.
Dass das jetzt ein System ist, was irgendwie nachvollziehbar ist.
Dass du nicht wie früher auf gut dünken, wenn irgendeiner von Twitter der Meinung ist, du bist prominent genug, dass du einen Haken kriegst, kriegst einen Haken.
Dass es irgendwie, sagen wir mal, ein halbwegs nachvollziehbares System ist jetzt.
Ich finde es prinzipiell gar nicht so verkehrt.
Aber die letzten paar Änderungen auf Twitter finde ich bescheuert.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch vorsichtig geworden, ob da nicht doch solche Sachen hier durchgesetzt werden.
So nach dem Motto, wir entfernen die Funktion.
Ja, sie können die Funktion vielleicht nicht entfernen, weil die Funktion von App Store Regeln sowohl bei Apple als auch bei Google vorgeschrieben ist.
Aber sie können sicherlich irgendwelche anderen Sachen machen, um das aufzuweichen.
Und im Endeffekt, wenn sie Twitter komplett gegen die Wand...
...wand fahren wollen, was immer mehr, ich habe es ja am Anfang nicht geglaubt, dass das der Fall sein könnte, immer mehr so aussieht, dann scheißen sie drauf, wird es halt aus dem App Store geschmissen und weiter.
Dann ist halt dead.
TweetDeck habe ich früher benutzt, schon ganz lang her.
Irgendwann war das, das war eine, das war damals glaube ich sogar noch eine Flash-Anwendung oder nee, nee, nicht Flash.
Leute, wie hieß diese Geschichte von Adobe?
Das war nicht Flash, sondern wie hieß dieses, dieses Applik...
Äh, eher, ja, ja.
Das meine ich, ganz vergessen.
Ja, ja, Adobe Air war das TweetDeck früher.
Und seit der Umstellung und seitdem das nicht mehr gescheit so lief, wie das damals...
Benutze ich, habe ich, ich habe das eine ganze Weile benutzt, benutze ich das auch nicht mehr.
War ein wirklich cooles Tool damals.
Seitdem benutze ich bloß noch die offizielle Twitter-App und, ja, im Endeffekt sonst nix, halt die Webseite und die App.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das trifft.
Wirklich wenige.
Ich habe was gelesen mit, du musst wie viel, 15 Millionen Impressionen haben.
Also ich, ich habe mal durchgeguckt.
Ich glaube, in Monaten, wo ich viel hochgeladen habe, also generell überall aktiv war,
viel Leute drauf waren und ich auch sehr viel auf Twitter gepostet habe und auch wirklich ganz recht erfolgreiche Posts dabei gewesen sind,
hatte ich, glaube ich, wenn es hoch kam, mal 2,5 Millionen Impressionen, wenn es hoch kam.
Nochmal, jetzt aktuell natürlich deutlich weniger.
Also ich, ich, also, kann das vergessen, ja, damit was zu verdienen.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ich twittere auch nicht, um damit Geld zu verdienen.
Also, keine Ahnung, also, das Problem ist, das Problem ist ja auch nicht so sehr, dass Twitter sackt,
sondern, dass ich mich frage, ob es irgendwelche Alternativen geben wird, die weniger sacken,
die nicht irgendwelche anderen, so, ja, No-Go-Sachen dabei haben, auf die ich gar keinen Bock habe
und die vor allem...
Die Masse der Leute benutzt, das ist ja das Ding, sowohl bei Twitter, bei Facebook, bei Instagram, bei allem, bei allem, was Social ist,
früher bei ICQ, bei, dann bei AOL Messenger, MSN Messenger, Skype, egal was du nimmst,
diese ganzen Social-Kommunikations-Tools, Network-Tools, die funktionieren ja nur, wenn andere Leute, guckt euch WhatsApp an und sonst was,
guckt mal, wie lang gibt es WhatsApp-Alternativen?
Das ist schon Telegram und, und Signal und sowas, Signal hat sich nie großartig durchgesetzt,
das ist einfach zu technisch für die meisten Leute, aber für das, was es halt machen soll, ganz gut.
Telegram hat sich noch so am meisten durchgesetzt, aber ganz ehrlich, WhatsApp ist immer noch das Größte
und wird es wahrscheinlich auch mit riesigem Abstand bleiben.
Letztendlich ist es ein sehr wichtiger Faktor bei diesen ganzen Social-Dingern, wie viele Leute drauf sind.
Deswegen wird sich Mastodon auch nicht so richtig...
durchsetzen, mag ja alles ganz schön und gut sein, aber was bringt es dir, wenn halt niemand da ist?
Ja, eins habe ich hier schon gelernt im Chat,
eins habe ich schon gelernt im Chat hier, wir sind nicht sonderlich repräsentativ für die Allgemeinheit, was technische Tools angeht.
Ich meine, wir haben ja sogar Leute, die verwenden E-Mags, Alter, kann man sich kaum ausmalen.
Also sind wir wirklich nicht repräsentativ für die allgemeine Technik, für die allgemeine Zustand, so der Leute.
Übrigens, zum Thema E-Mags, letztens auf der Arbeit war ich in einem Call, wo ein Dienstleister dabei war
und da zeigt er auf einmal ein paar Configs und was macht er auf?
E-Mags! E-Mags, da dachte ich mir mal, ich glaube, das letzte Mal E-Mags habe ich vor acht Jahren oder so gesehen, bei mir selbst.
Ich kann dazu nichts Qualifiziertes sagen, weil ich verwende weder WhatsApp noch Telegram.
Also keine Ahnung. Wir benutzen hier auch alle Arsch, hoffe ich mal.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, wir machen mal kurz Package-Updates.
Wenn die Signal verwenden auf der Arbeit, wegen, ja, also Signal ist das Einzige, wo ich mal ein bisschen so rumgeguckt habe, was die machen
und denen ich glaube, dass es quasi kleinseitig verschlüsselt und nicht abhörbar ist.
Ne, das meine ich gar nicht. Sorry, nicht Signal.
Trema meinte ich, nicht Signal. Vergesst es, ich habe das verwechselt.
Trema benutzt keiner.
Und das ist das Einzige, den ich mich das letzte Mal damit beschäftigt habe, vor ein paar Jahren, den ich das abgekauft habe,
dass die wirklich kleinseitig verschlüsseln, ohne dass es irgendjemand mitlesen kann.
Trema, verwendet das überhaupt noch irgendjemand?
Oder Threema, oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Ich glaube, das hat nie jemand. Ich habe das gerade verwechselt.
Es gibt, wir haben hier, es gibt ja mehrere. Es gibt ja WhatsApp, Telegram, Signal.
Die sind ja alle drei relativ groß, wobei WhatsApp mit Abstand der Größte und nicht gefolgt von Telegram, glaube ich.
Ja, das ist halt das Ding.
Oh, ich wusste gar nicht, ich wusste gar nicht mehr, dass das was kostet.
Kostet das was? Hat das schon immer was gekostet?
Naja, zumindest, es ist halt das gleiche Ding.
Du brauchst für diese ganzen Social Sachen immer eine gewisse Verbreitung.
Und das hat halt aktuell in dem Segment nur Twitter.
Also mal gucken, mal gucken, was Facebook und mal ganz im Ernst, so sehr die Leute das irgendwie feiern mit,
mit, wie heißt es, Threads und so
von Instagram beziehungsweise Facebook.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich
lieber einen Service vom Zug verwenden
will, als einen Service vom Elon.
Irgendwie gibt sich das, gibt sich das, glaube
ich, nix. Und selbst,
ja, ich weiß, die Leute sagen jetzt, ja,
aber mit Threads kannst du ja
Mastodon und alles mögliche anbinden.
Ganz ehrlich, das machen
die so lange,
wie das für sie von Vorteil ist
und danach wird der Support
immer weiter zurückgebaut. Die wollen die User
absaugen erstmal, von dem,
die easy zu haben sind
und dann wird das immer weiter, immer weiter
reduziert und inkompatibel
gemacht, so Microsoft-Taktik und irgendwann
klappt es nicht mehr richtig.
X-Defiant spielen, das
habe ich sogar
schon mal
installiert und bei Ubisoft
in diesem scheiß Ubisoft-Launcher.
Aber
ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht gespielt.
Ist gerade wieder,
ist gerade wieder, wann ist denn da Release?
Ist gerade wieder irgendein Beta-Wochenende
oder ist das mittlerweile raus? Ich habe das überhaupt
nicht mehr verfolgt. Wirst du Starfield
spielen? Ich weiß nicht genau.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich war nie der große Fallout-Fan
und, keine Ahnung,
das weiß ich nicht.
Es gibt ja noch viele Games, die ich
erstmal spielen muss. Ich wollte zum
Beispiel schon seit Release
dieses, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie es
heißt, Atomic
oder so hieß das doch. Ist das nicht Atomic?
Dieses, das russische
Bioshock
spielen.
Ich habe mir das gekauft zu Release, installiert,
aber nie gespielt. Ist das nicht
Atomic?
Russisches Bioshock.
Atomic.
Atomic Hard.
Ja, das meinte ich.
Genialer Hint. Du meinst den hier?
Der ist Pog, ne?
Du kannst diesen Hintergrund übrigens selbst
benutzen. Und zwar
du gehst bei mir
auf Github.
White-Pepo-Happy-Desktop.
Und hier hast du alle, für jede
Tageszeit hast du einen.
Guckst sogar den Workout-Pepo.
Und wenn du Lilux benutzt, kannst du
auch irgendeins von den beiden Skripts verwenden,
zum automatischen Background setzen. Ihr werdet sehen,
alle 10 Minuten ändert er sich und immer
der Tageszeit.
Das ist ja auch,
das ist ja quasi der Windows XP Hintergrund,
nur noch etwas
weiter weg vom
Original.
So, haben wir jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Ich hab, ich hab gar nicht geguckt. Ich glaub schon.
Reboot.
Ja, das ist nice. Factorio fand ich
auch mega Pog.
Factorio ist auch so ein Spiel, das kann man
theoretisch Jahrzehnte spielen.
Gerade mit den ganzen Mods dabei.
Das kannst du täglich Jahrzehnte spielen
fast, wenn du dich da komplett, also wenn
du da komplett drinnen abgehst.
Alle 10 Minuten.
Ne, da kommen auch schon ab und zu mal die gleichen Hintergründe.
Ich hab's einfach
eingestellt, dass sich das alle 10 Minuten ändert.
Der Tageszeit
entsprechend.
Es kann auch sein, dass die Bilder doppelt kommen.
So viele Bilder sind es. Ich glaub, es sind
aktuell, keine Ahnung, 20,
25 Bilder oder sowas.
Ja. So.
Pepo Sonnenuntergang.
White Pepo Happy.
Also white,
nicht white. Jetzt kommen die Leute wieder.
Pepo.
Nicht, dass der Pepo noch ein weißer alter Mann
ist. Das wollen wir ja nicht.
Weißer alter Frosch.
So, jetzt können wir die VM wieder ausmachen.
Ja,
Twitter. Wobei, das ist, ohne Scheiß,
wahrscheinlich ist dafür
das einzig Gute daran, wenn
Twitter untergeht.
Die Leute können nicht mal ganz so
krass Circle Jerken auf irgendwas.
Wundert
mich nicht.
Es ist ein naheliegender,
naheliegendes
Emote dann, wenn es
White Pepo Happy schon gibt.
But allerdings, Bums, danke für den Sub, Leute.
Ich hab wieder die Hälfte vergessen.
Vorzulesen, glaub ich. Moment.
Creator Dashboard.
Nö.
Zoa hat subscribed gestern.
Warum zum...
Warum zum Teufel
followed mir die Marmeladen-Oma?
The fuck?
Ich hab die mal vor drei Jahren
oder so gehostet.
Hä?
Das ist ne Oma, die liest immer irgendwelche
Märchen und Geschichten vor.
Die hab ich mal gehostet
vor drei Jahren oder so.
Hast du schon mal überlegt,
einen Keks-VTUBE-Avatar zu machen?
Ja, hab ich.
Tatsächlich hab ich das schon überlegt.
Aber es ist unglaublich schwierig,
irgendjemanden zu finden,
der fähig ist,
sowas zu erstellen.
Ich hab schon...
Seit einer geraumen Zeit bin ich danach am gucken,
ob irgendjemand...
Aber ich find keinen, der das
gescheit hinkriegt, beziehungsweise der sagt,
ja, ich kann sowas.
Bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch irgendwelche Leute
befeilten.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung,
wo ich nicht gescheit weiß, was da rauskommt.
Es wird natürlich ein bisschen teurer werden,
weil es schon ganz schön viel Arbeitsaufwand bedeutet.
Also wenn das ordentlich gemodelt ist
und, wie heißt das, gerickt.
Wenn das so mit virtuellen Knochen
versorgt wird, soll ich so ein Model...
Aber
das macht ja nix. Das kann auch ein bisschen was kosten,
aber es muss halt auch was Gescheites bei rauskommen.
Ey, ey Leute, ich verdien nicht...
Letztens hat mich auf der Arbeit
jemand doch gefragt, tatsächlich,
sag mal, was kann man mit YouTube so verdienen?
Hab ich auch gemeint, man kann mit YouTube
enorm viel verdienen, aber ich verdien nicht viel mit YouTube.
Dazu müsste ich halt mal
ein bisschen mehr hochladen und ein bisschen mehr
Sellout machen und alles, alles ein bisschen mehr
Content-Creator-mäßig
2023 angehen.
Aber ihr kennt mich, bin ich viel zu faul,
dafür hab ich gar keinen Bock.
Ja, das weiß ich. Es gibt ein paar, die können so
2D-Anime-Style-Avatare
machen oder 3D.
Ich fände einen 2D-Keks
tatsächlich deutlich passender als
einen 3D-Keks.
Für die meisten Leute ist es deutlich
einfacher, einen Avatar zu machen, der menschlich
aussieht, als einen
ja, etwas abstrakten
Keks-Avatar.
Du verdienst aktuell mehr mit Twitch, oder?
Ach, so pauschal
kann man das nicht sagen. Also,
wenn das ein Monat ist, also
nicht unbedingt. Also, hier,
wenn man sich das auf
YouTube anguckt, ja, die letzten
zwei, also, wenn man jetzt mal diesen
Monat hier nimmt, ja, da gab's
quasi hier, es gab drei
Videos und die sind alle recht gut angekommen.
Dann kann das schon mal
mehr sein, aber
in der Regel ist es
mit Twitch mehr, ja.
Bist du privat noch Kontakt mit dem Friseur?
Ja, selten. Also, ich meine,
wir werden wahrscheinlich immer ab und zu mal
irgendwie ein bisschen was schreiben. Wir kannten uns ja auch
schon vor YouTube und allem Möglichen, aber
jetzt in letzter Zeit ist relativ wenig, weil
ja, gibt halt nichts, was man groß zusammen
spielen kann und ich weiß auch, ich weiß auch ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht, was der gerade macht. Da macht
der Laufen irgendwas anderes.
Wie ist das da?
Hi, Frisi.
Zeig mal, wann war der zuletzt on? War der irgendwann mal zuletzt
mal on?
Hä?
Dachte, dachte eigentlich, der wollte ein bisschen Diablo 4 streamen.
Hat er, glaube ich, auch.
Aber nicht irgendwie
einmal oder so. Ja, das ist
keine schlechte Seite.
Weil du das Gate 3 kamst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Fabian auf sowas steht.
Eigentlich dachte ich, meine Fahne Dragon Age,
das weiß ich, Dragon Age Origins
fand der mega damals.
War ja auch ein richtig gutes Game.
Und ich glaube, von
ohne Mist, alle, von den ganzen RPGs,
die es bisher so gibt,
kommt, glaube ich, Baldur's Gate 3
am ehesten
in diese Richtung wie
Dragon Age Origins.
Ich finde, die beiden Games sind sich doch ziemlich ähnlich.
Also mal davon abgesehen,
dass es halt reines
rundenbasiertes Ding ist, aber so
vom Style,
von der Kamera, von der
Grafik, allem.
Ich finde, Dragon Age Origins und Baldur's Gate 3
ist sich da doch recht,
auch vom Dialogsystem und sowas,
ist sich doch schon recht, von den Quests
und sowas, ist doch schon ein bisschen ähnlich.
Aber keine Ahnung, ob der Baldur's Gate 3 spielt.
Oh, schon lange nichts mehr gehört.
Oh, doch habe ich.
Ich habe letztens, ich habe mein Handy
auf Do Not Disturb
und da habe ich letztens
reingeguckt, habe gesehen, er hat mich versucht anzurufen
vor zwei Wochen oder so.
Ich habe das irgendwie erst wieder fünf Tage später gesehen.
Und ihr kennt mich
so Social-Dinger. Ich habe mir gedacht,
ach gut, das ist jetzt fünf Tage her, ist auch doof.
Dann
dachte man lieber nichts.
Aber er ist das der Einzige auf YouTube, mit dem ich
wirklich gut verstanden habe, so die
Jahre, wo wir da aktiv waren.
Da kann ich echt nichts Schlechtes sagen.
Das liegt, ihr kennt mich,
so soziale Sachen, mit
Leuten telefonieren und so.
Neue Battlefields, echt, wann ist es denn so weit?
Wann ist es denn so weit?
7. Juni,
ja gut, das sind ja noch drei Wochen oder vier Wochen.
1, 2, 3, ja,
drei Wochen.
Okay, ja, das gucken wir uns mal wieder an.
Da bin ich gespannt,
ob es noch mehr Kisten gibt.
Das gibt es, das existiert, glaube ich,
nirgendwo mehr.
Nutzt du ein OCR-System für
Paperless-Dokumente?
Ehrlich gesagt, ne, mach ich nicht.
Ich scanne manche Sachen ein, das ist aber ganz simpel.
Ich habe einen Drucker, der kann entweder
auf Netzwerkshare pushen oder auf einen USB-Stick.
Aber da macht er kein OCR.
Wobei ich gar nicht sicher bin.
Ich glaube, dass das sogar
teilweise ein bisschen geht damit.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht gut.
Und ansonsten habe ich eine
Etage im Schrank.
Da sind ein paar Fächer drin
und da pfeffer ich einfach alles rein
und
scanne das dann ein und schicke es
einmal im Jahr an den Steuerberater. Fertig.
7. Juni.
New Dawn, das haben wir doch
gespielt, oder? Haben wir New Dawn gespielt?
Alter, was ist das für eine hässliche Seite?
Season 6.
Der Jura, danke.
Vielen Dank für den Sub.
Season 6 Release Date im Oktober.
Wie jetzt?
Im August?
Ja, wann denn jetzt?
Wie ist es nicht?
Geil.
Okay, die Games hat einfach keinen Bock.
Alles klar.
Es kommt erst mal eine Mini Season.
Ach ja, dann haben wir das gespielt mit der Schneekarte.
Ja, ja, das kenne ich.
Das haben wir gespielt.
Hast du eigentlich von dem Update für frühe COD-Teile?
Habe ich mitgekriegt, aber
war es nicht ein Problem auf dem PC
die alten Call of Duty-Teile zu spielen,
weil die Leute dich ganz einfach
mit irgendwelchen Viren
infizieren können
durch irgendwelche
Buffer-Overflows
im Call of Duty-Client?
Gab es da nicht gravierende
Sicherheitslücken bei alten Call of Duty-Teilen?
Da war was. Ich habe da immer
einen großen Bogen drum gemacht.
Ja, Leute, morgen früh wieder aufwachen, streamen.
Wir können uns noch ein paar Videos angucken.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Oh, guck mal, was ist das?
PHP does not suck anymore.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das glauben soll,
dass PHP nicht mehr suckt.
Also ich habe PHP ausprobiert vor ein paar Wochen
und ich war der Meinung, dass
Ja, ich habe PHP ausprobiert vor ein paar Wochen und ich war der Meinung, dass
danach das PHP eigentlich immer noch suckt.
Das Video ist nicht eher, aber PHP suckt.
Vielleicht PHP nicht mehr selbst, aber das Ökosystem und so,
das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Ich weiß, jetzt kommen gleich wieder die Leute um die Ecke.
Max, wann gibt es endlich den Rust-Rewrite?
Es wird Zeit, Leute.
Haha, Max muss Rust-Rewrite machen.
Nein, ich muss keinen Rust-Rewrite machen.
Vorher mache ich eher einen C++-Rewrite,
bevor ich den Rust-Rewrite mache.
Das ist auch so ein Ding unter Windows,
was mir mega auf den Sack geht.
Warum, by the way,
by the way, Leute,
warum kann man diese
Kack-Ich-Suche-im-Internet-Option
nicht abschalten?
Das geht nicht.
Ja, man kann nur
dual content filtern.
Ich will gar kein
Internet-Search bei mir haben.
Nur über Registry-Key.
Das ist so ein Kack, Alter.
Immer noch da
Welttag der Fotografie, Alter, wen juckt's
Was ist eigentlich daran so schlimm
Naja, also
Zwei Sachen, schau dir mal
Auf so Pauschalen, die mir einfallen
Erstens
Es geht mir auf den Sack
Hä, Moment
Ist es jetzt weg
Äh, hä
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist es jetzt weg
Ähm, ja, und
Und das zweite Problem ist, dass meine Suchanfragen
Im Zweifelsfall zu Microsoft geschickt werden
Vielleicht will ich das ja gar nicht
Ach, bei Rust, wieso
Naja, Rust ist nix Schlimmes
Ich hab aber keinen Bock, die Sachen in Rust
Zu rewriten, weil es macht keinen Sinn
Was zu funktioniert, zu rewriten
Einfach nur, damit das in Rust rewritet werden kann
Wie gesagt, das sieht
Die Rust Taskforce
Auf Hacker News sicherlich anders
Aber es gibt ja auch auf GitHub
Ich mein, guck mal, GitHub
Rust Rewrite
Die Hälfte
Die Hälfte der Rust Projekte
Auf GitHub
Ist ein
Ich habe rewritet in Rust
Aber Placing the Fast, guckt euch das an
Ja
Guck mal, ich mein
LS
LS wird rewritet in Rust
Und
Ich hab auch mal ne Weile Exa verwendet
Hab ich das überhaupt noch
Ne, hab ich nicht mehr
Ähm, aber ich seh einfach
Keinen Sinn drinne
Warum nicht einfach LS
LS ist perfectly fine, ja
Nekorock, dankeschön für den Sub
Es gibt zig solcher, solcher Tools, ja
Das ist das mit den Icons
Siehste mal, das kenn ich doch gar nicht
Was ist nut?
Das ist schon abandoned seit zwei Jahren
Das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, warum ich
Solange es nichts in diesen neuen Tools gibt
Was so viel besser ist
Bei den alten Tools bleibe
LS wird halt einfach nicht deprecated
LS wirds halt immer geben
AM wurde rewritet
Warum wurde AM rewritet?
Damit
Ja, damit LS 1% schnell ist
Aber muss halt ehrlich sagen, LS
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Guck mal
Das ist nicht, hier, okay
Ja, nice
Es hat 4 Millisekunden gedauert
Ich glaube, das muss eindeutig
Placing the Fast gemacht werden
Das ist wichtig
Ich glaube, 4 Millisekunden sind schon
Ganz schön problematisch
Interaktiv auf der Shell
Ich glaube, da kann ich nicht mit leben
Das muss in Rust rewritet werden
Compare mal zu der Rust Variante
Okay, das machen wir jetzt
Achtung
Ich hab doch extra sogar noch installiert
So
Also, compare mir mal das
Mit dem, okay?
4 Millisekunden
Versus
Versus 3 Millisekunden
Okay
5 Millisekunden
Also 4 Millisekunden
Versus 3 bis 5 Millisekunden
Beides
Ich mein, man kann das bestimmt
Warte mal, man kann das wahrscheinlich
User
Bin Time minus V
Das ist BSD Time
Wie heißt denn das?
Ähm
Time?
Es gibt ja ein advanceres Time Tool
So
Okay
Nice, so das hat gebraucht
Wie lange jetzt?
Okay, das war so schnell, dass es
Ja gut, Sekunden hat das nicht gebraucht
So, Millisekunden gibt es nicht
Ja, super, geil
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich merke da keinen Unterschied
Man müsste vielleicht mal
Ein etwas längeres Verzeichnis machen
Das probieren wir jetzt aus
Ich mache jetzt
Ein Verzeichnis
Ja, Temp
Irgendwas drinnen
Ne, Temp, so, Touch
Wie viele Dateien machen wir?
Hier, ich will meine VM nicht überlasten
10.000 Dateien, 100.000 Dateien
Bam, so
Okay, jetzt brauchst du ein bisschen länger
Okay, Blazingly Fast
Blazingly Fast, Time
Okay, 437 Millisekunden
Time
ExaLA
Ah, guck mal
Der Rust Rewrite ist langsamer
Ich kann euch auch sagen
Warum der Rust Rewrite langsamer ist
Das ist ganz offensichtlich
Der Rust Rewrite ist wegen mehr Farben langsamer
Mehr Farben
Bedeuten mehr Text Output
Man musste Color ausstellen
Color, kann man sowas hier machen?
Color
Gleich Off oder so, ne
Never
Ah, trotzdem
Trotzdem
Guck mal
LS ist einfach schneller als der Rust Rewrite
Also warum soll ich den Rust Rewrite verwenden?
Von wegen Blazingly Fast
Exposed
Nein, nein, nein
Auf gar keinen Fall
Aber, aber was ist denn der Sinn
Dann zu Rewriten in Rust
Wenn das Original noch Blazingly Faster ist
Ich verstehe das bei manchen
Tools wie grep zum Beispiel
Wenn Leute dann irgendwie
Das Linux Kernel Verzeichnis durchgreppen wollen
Weniger Crashes
Klar
LS crasht auch so oft
Chat, hattet ihr einmal
Jemals einen
Crash von LS
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob LS überhaupt crashen kann
Git
Ja
Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen
Ich find's mit Farben schöner
Ja, aber es ist auch nicht mal Blazingly Fast
Also ich hab tatsächlich ne Weile
Extra verwendet
Weil ich das auch cooler fand
Dass man hier das richtig erkennt
Aber ich muss sagen
Ich komme mit
Der Sache hier
Mittlerweile mit LS
Irgendwie angenehmer klar
Es ist überall drauf
Du hast dich an die Optionen gewöhnt
Und da schützt du auch nicht 1 zu 1
Alles wie LS
Dann Terminal Rewrite in Rust
Mein Terminal ist in Rust programmiert
Das hier, das ist ein Rust Based Terminal
Ihr guckt, Rust
Ja
Rust basiertes Terminal
Also ich hatte jetzt quasi ein Rust LS
In einem Rust Terminal
Also viel schneller kann es sein
Viel Blazingly Faster wird's ja nicht mehr
Das ist Blazingly
Steep Fast
As fuck
Und trotzdem ist das Standard LS schneller
Also hat sich aus
Blazingly Faster
Zumindest als LS Alternative
Wollen wir uns das PHP Video angucken
Und
Chatge und
Irgendjemand bei euch am Start
Von denen die letztens geschrieben haben
Ich krieg das leider nicht mal aus dem Kopf zusammen
Wer das alles gewesen ist
Die Bewerbung geschickt haben
Gibt es bei euch irgendwas neues
Wurdet ihr genommen
Wie war das Vorstellungsgespräch
Wie war es so falls irgendjemand von denen da ist
Es hat in letzter Zeit recht häufig
Jemand was geschrieben in der Richtung
Es haben sich auch schon ein paar zurück gemeldet
Neue Storys gibt
Du hast zwei Verträge vorlegen
Ich hoffe beides big stonks money
Ich hab Montag und Dienstag
Team Meetings
Kennenlernen
Erstes Mal so gucken
Wie die Leute drauf sind
Ja
Habe ich nur einmal
Nein zweimal
Zweimal habe ich das gemacht
Zwei Stunden
Die wollen es aber wissen
Also
Ich habe das einmal gemacht
In letzter Zeit
Das war glaube ich 45 Minuten
Da habe ich sie etwas verwirrt
Ich glaube das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt
Du kannst den Teams ja so blocken
Dass die Leute in das Meeting können
Bevor nicht irgendjemand in dem Meeting drin ist
Und die Leute zulässt
Aber Teams auf dem Handy
Kann diese Beschränkung nicht
Und joint auch geblockten Meetings
Und da war ich schon in dem Meeting
Und habe in die Kamera gewunken da kam erst die Frau von der Personalabteilung rein
Warum bist du schon hier
Ich habe das Meeting noch gar nicht gestartet
Migdiet
Pogsubscription
Gibt es ja keine neuen Azubis
Ganz ehrlich
Was ist die Alternative zu Teams
Zoom oder wie
Ganz ehrlich
Ich finde Teams ist zwar
Sehr bloated mittlerweile
Und ist auch nicht die schnellste Anwendung
Ich verwende es übrigens auch nur im Browser
Aber
Die Alternativen die ich da bisher gesehen habe
Skype for Business
Kennt das noch jemand
Hat jemand von euch mal die Ehre Skype for Business verwenden zu müssen
Das ist richtiger Schrott
Massive Schrott
Zoom musste ich letztens mit einem Dienstleister
In einen Zoom Call
Das hat mich auch nicht gerade
Begeistert
Ja aber Slack kann sicherlich
Bei weitem nicht alles
An Kommunikation was Teams kann
Ich weiß es nicht weil ich Slack
So nicht benutzt habe
In dem Umfang wie Teams
Aber Teams hat ja so viele
Teams kann es ja so mittlerweile
An Telefonanlagen anbinden
Und sowas
Okay WebEx fand ich auch immer abartig
WebEx noch schlimmer
Teams frisst halt ohne Ende RAM
Das ist richtig
Aber also WebEx ist
Leute ich wusste mal
Wo wir gerade bei komischen Videokonferenzsystemen sind
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit
Da gab es noch Videokonferenzanlagen
Da ist man dann
Wenn man mit Leuten an einem anderen Standort reden wollte
In den Videokonferenzraum gegangen
Und ich musste mal
Eine Videokonferenzanlage aufbauen
Von
Trantberg hieß das glaube ich
Das sind irgendwelche Schweden
Nein die wurden von Cisco gekauft anscheinend mittlerweile
Das ähm
Äh
Sah gar nicht mal so unähnlich aus
Dazu
Ja so in der Richtung
Ja so sah das
Aber noch älter
Aber so in der Richtung sah das aus
Und das Ding
War jedes mal kaputt
Und hat Probleme gemacht
Bei jeder Videokonferenz
Hat irgendwas nicht funktioniert
Das war so schlecht
Und das hat irgendwie 10.000 Euro oder sowas gekostet
So ein Ding
Das war so kacke
Das war schon das richtige Meme damals bei uns
Auf der Arbeit
Das ist schon lange her
Da war ich noch beim Internet Provider damals
Das war schon so das Meme bei uns
Das Fakt ist
Ich bin sehr stolz
Aber wenn ich jetzt aber an wenn man
Ein Lachback Ding
Als nächstes für Probleme hat
Ja das liegt aber wahrscheinlich an euch
Und nicht an Microsoft
Wegen irgendwelchen komischen Policies
Und Sachen
Vielleicht muss bei euch erst einer
Das Bild abnehmen
Oder sowas
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht an Microsoft liegen
Oder vielleicht liegt es auch an deinem Browser Cache
Ist das nicht so?
Mit der man Barcodes einlesen kann.
Ah ne, Barco hieß das.
Ja, die meine ich.
QR-Code scannen, ja.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich auch der größte Vorteil,
wenn man eben auf dieses Microsoft-Ökosystem steht,
dann passt halt Teams ganz gut rein.
Ich meine, ich mache einen großen Bogen drum.
Es ist so ein Ding, bei uns auf der Arbeit,
also in meinem Team,
da gibt es ein paar Leute,
sagen wir mal so, bestimmt 80% des Teams,
die stehen unglaublich auf OneNote.
Und ich kriege jedes Mal komplette Anfälle,
wenn ich OneNote benutzen muss.
Ich benutze das einfach nicht.
Ich schreibe halt manchmal ein paar Sachen rein,
so, wenn es nicht anders geht.
Aber ich habe einfach Text-Files,
die ich durchcappen kann.
Fertig.
Ohne Mist, dann würde ich das sogar lieber ins Confluence schreiben.
Wusstet ihr, dass OneNote keine Substring-Suche kann?
Du findest in OneNote nichts.
Also mal angenommen, du hast jetzt in OneNote stehen,
du hast so einen Befehl,
sag mal curlkeckel.com
slash blub123.
So, und du weißt,
du weißt, dass in diesem Befehl irgendwie blub gleich drinne vorkommt, ja?
Und du suchst blub gleich in OneNote, das geht nicht.
Blub findet nur curl oder keckel in dem Fall.
Die Suche funktioniert nur an Wortgrenzen in OneNote.
Mega, mega beschissen ist das.
Richtiger Müll.
Vielleicht kann man das in den Settings irgendwie umstellen,
dass das eben dann nicht vom Index,
sondern direkt zur Suche, zur Lineare drüberscannen Suche wechselt.
Aber mega beschissen.
OneNote ist komplett unbrauchbar für mich.
Also ist es im Browser jetzt besser?
Was denn?
Du meinst Teams?
Wenn du Linux verwendest, bleibt dir nichts alles übrig,
als den Browser zu verwenden.
Und ich benutze es aber auch unter Windows,
am liebsten im Browser.
Eigentlich auch einfach, weil ich es nicht zusätzlich installiert haben muss.
Ja, Confluence haben wir auch.
Die haben eh, dort wo ich aktuell arbeite,
die haben eh 30 Milliarden Systeme.
Alles doppelt und dreifach.
Das ganz alte OneNote, das ganz, ganz alte OneNote
habe ich auch mal eine Weile verwendet.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Confluence nur als Cloud-Lösung gibt.
Es gibt Confluence Data Center und Confluence Cloud.
Ich glaube, Data Center gibt es auch weiter zum Selbstinstallieren.
Oder? Chat-Gil, kennt sich jemand mit Atlassian-Shit aus?
Ja, Obsidian würde ich tatsächlich auch benutzen, also privat.
Wenn es eine Sache hätte, die es leider nicht hat,
und zwar, dass du Termine eintragen kannst,
die auch mobile funktionieren.
Active Inspire, das kenne ich nicht.
Das hört sich an, wie irgendein Spell aus dem MMO.
Active Inspire.
Active Inspire Unterrichtssoftware, oh je.
Das klingt Painz-Champ.
Von Lehrenden für Lehrenden, was?
Alter.
Kann man nicht einfach Schüler schreiben, Alter?
Das geht mir so auf den Sack teilweise.
Ich habe hier nichts dagegen, wenn Leute das gerne machen
und das untereinander verwenden oder so.
Aber es ist teilweise einfach beschissen zu verstehen, Mann.
Ich muss mir das mal angucken, was machen die dann?
Dann nennen sie es irgendwie anders.
Dann nennen sie es Schüler-Studenten.
Was auch immer.
Von Lehrenden für Lehrende.
Ich kann den Satz noch nicht mehr aussprechen.
Von Lehrenden für Lehrende entwickelt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich verstehe nicht, was das mir sagen soll.
Das ist quasi von Lehrern für Lehrer, wollen die damit sagen, oder wie?
Von Lehrern für Lehrer.
Dann schreibt es halt von Lehrer für Lehrer.
Hahaha.
Meine Güte.
Alter.
Ich handhab's ja normalerweise so, es soll jeder machen, was er will.
Aber in dem Fall, die wollen ja was verkaufen.
Das hätte schon seinen Vorteil, wenn man es auf den ersten Blick versteht.
Selbstverständlich können sie machen, was sie wollen.
Aber ich habe es halt nicht gecheckt.
Media-Wiki ist auch ganz nice.
Ich persönlich mag Doku-Wiki eigentlich immer noch.
Leider hat Doku-Wiki halt immer noch diese blöde Doku-Wiki-Syntax.
Wenn man Markdown gewöhnt ist, ist Doku...
Doku-Wiki-Syntax.
Blöd.
Das richtig coole an Doku-Wiki ist, dass alles Plaintext ist.
An Daten.
So, okay.
Was...
Euer Lehrer verwendet...
Moment.
Active Inspire.
Was haben die denn so?
Classflow.
Active Inspire.
Jeder Unterricht wird zu einem echten Erlebnis.
Ja, aber bestimmt nicht wegen Active Inspire.
Muss man in Offenbach an die Schule.
Da ist sicherlich jeder Unterricht zum Erlebnis.
Wenn dann einer das Messer rausholt oder sowas.
Ganz selbstverständlich digital unterrichten.
Okay, ganz ehrlich.
Das sieht natürlich cool aus.
Wenn das dann alles so funktioniert.
Moment, Moment.
Hat der da Paint auf im Hintergrund?
Ist das Paint?
Das ist nicht so richtig touch-friendly, oder?
Nee, das ist nicht Paint.
Das ist sowas ähnliches.
Das ist die Software.
Aber ganz schön klein, oder?
Ich meine, guck mal, wie dick der Finger von ihm ist.
Da trifft es ja die Farbe noch immer richtig.
Zehn großartige Vorteile.
Ich glaube, mein Darkreader macht es kaputt.
Zehn großartige Vorteile von Active Inspire.
Verwenden Sie den virtuellen Würfel im Mathematikunterricht.
Das ist doch eher ein Glücksrad, oder?
Das ist doch gar kein Würfel.
Ändern Sie den Drehpunkt eines beliebigen Objekts.
Boah, noch nie da gewesen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das wieder so ein Tool, was ganz gut ist, wenn die Lehrer damit umgehen können.
Ich will jetzt nichts Schlechtes über die sagen, weil ich kenne die Software nicht.
Es könnte nämlich auch sein, ich weiß nicht, wer es hier geschrieben hat,
dass einfach euer Lehrer sackt im Umgang damit.
Weil sowas muss ja pauschal nicht schlecht sein.
Wie gesagt, Sie können auch einfach schreiben, von Lehrern für Lehrer.
Oder was ich persönlich noch besser finde, von Lehrkörpern für Lehrkörper.
Wenn ich mir nicht genau sicher bin, wie man die schreibt, mit EH oder mit 2E.
Die haben massive Probleme mit Treibern.
Wie kann man massive Probleme mit Treibern haben, bei der selbst hergestellten Hardware-Software-Kombination?
Das Programm unterstützt keinen Touch. Du musst das Board so einstellen, dass es die Maus als Finger eckt.
What?
Du meinst, dass es den Finger als Maus erkennt, oder?
Weil wenn es keinen Touch unterstützt, muss es ja nicht den Finger ecken.
Was genau machst du auf der Arbeit?
Ich habe gerade eine interessante Story aus dem aktuellen Sprint.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwas Spannendes gibt, was Sinn macht, zu erzählen.
Ich muss es ja immer ein bisschen anonymisieren.
Ich weiß nicht, fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts ein.
Hört mir jetzt gerade nichts ein.
Wir schlagen uns mit schlecht verpacketierter Software vor einem Hersteller rum.
Die schaffen es jedes Mal.
Leute, die haben es letztens geschafft.
Doch, eine Sache kann ich euch erzählen.
Wir haben eine Software gekauft, von einem Hersteller.
Ich sage euch jetzt nicht, welche Hersteller, welche Software.
Und die ist dafür ausgelegt, in einem Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, wie auch immer, Cluster zu laufen.
Und die liefern ein offizielles Helm-Chart mit.
Das ist quasi Setup-Axe für Kubernetes. So könnt ihr euch das vorstellen.
So, und die haben es geschafft bisher, bei jedem Release irgendwas Grundlegendes kaputt zu machen.
Passt mal auf, ich zeige euch mal ein kleines Beispiel, was die geschafft haben, beim letzten Release kaputt zu machen.
Und zwar, die haben Images im Kubernetes-Manifest so geschrieben.
Hier, Image, keine Ahnung, registry.max, slash, image, slash, 1.0.0.
So, Chat-G, wer ist HiAQ-Docker-Registry-Kubernetes-Kenner?
Was ist daran falsch?
Es ist eigentlich offensichtlich, wenn man das öfters sieht.
Die Version ist falsch, richtig.
Hier muss ein Doppelpunkt sein, anstatt ein Slash, korrekt.
Und ich habe einen Upgrade gemacht, von 1.9.0 auf 1.9.1, war das, glaube ich.
Ich habe einen Upgrade gemacht, und auf einmal geht nichts mehr, weil alle Images nicht mehr pullen.
Weil sie einen Slash hier hingeschrieben haben, in ihrem Template, anstatt einen Doppelpunkt.
Und das sind so Dinge, wo ich mich halt frage, wie kann das passieren?
Jeder, wirklich jeder, egal wie minimalistischer Test, ob es funktioniert, was man gemacht hat, sollte diesen Fehler abfangen.
Weil das Image wird falsch getemplated.
Das heißt, egal was man macht, es startet nie.
Es kann nie das Image pullen, weil das einfach syntaktisch falsch ist, dass ein Slash an der Stelle ist.
Also, keine Ahnung, was die da treiben.
Und die machen halt öfters so Zeug.
Also, Chat, wenn ich eine so Universal-Weisheit in der IT gelernt habe, die letzten 15 Jahre über,
wenn eine Software kompliziert zu installieren ist, sodass man sich da wirklich ein paar Tage mit beschäftigen muss,
bis man verstanden hat, bis man es mal Proof-of-Concept-mäßig installiert bekommt,
dann ist die Software es meistens nicht wert, benutzt zu werden.
SAP-Consultants werden mir jetzt widersprechen, weil die verdienen mit dem Scheiß ihr Geld.
Aber wenn eine Software kompliziert zu installieren ist, sodass es nicht möglich ist, die innerhalb von Minuten bis ein paar Stunden
da eine Demo hinzustellen, ist es meistens nicht wert zu benutzen.
Das heißt nicht, dass eine Software nicht schwierig installieren zu sein kann mit allen Optionen,
aber die Minimalkonfiguration und so in einem Wir-wollen-es-uns-einfach-mal-angucken-Modus muss schnell gehen.
Guckt euch zum Beispiel GitLab an.
GitLab ist der Abfuck-Extrem zu installieren.
Aber du kriegst es doch relativ, relativ simpel.
In einem kleinen Demo-Modus zum Laufen mit Docker.
GitLab ausgebaut ist der Abfuck komplett.
Macht ihr denn wirklich Scrum nach Lehrplan?
Naja, nachdem es kein offizielles, einzig gültiges How-to gibt, wie man Scrum macht,
würde ich sagen, wir machen Scrum doch relativ,
relativ dementsprechend, was man sich darunter vorstellen würde.
Mit Daily-Absprachen, mit Sprintplanung, mit Retrospektive, was man besser machen kann,
mit Planen fürs nächste Mal, mit Review, was gelaufen ist,
mit kleinen Abschnitten, dass man es sich vorstellen kann.
Wir machen das, glaube ich, ziemlich lehrbuchmäßig.
Natürlich, insgesamt ist halt immer die Frage, ob man es wirklich ganz so extrem zelebrieren muss.
Ich denke, die beste agile Methodik ist die, die im jeweiligen Unternehmen gut funktioniert.
Ob die jetzt wirklich aus dem Lehrbuch ist, oder anhand dessen, was irgendein Consultant da mal,
oder Scrum-Coach die gecoacht hat, ist doch wurscht.
Aber so wie die das machen, funktioniert das ganz gut.
Es ist nicht übertrieben, es ist alle zwei Wochen Dienstag übertrieben, weil alle zwei Wochen Dienstag,
das war übrigens die, diese, ich glaube diese Woche war das,
diese Woche Dienstag war das, da war wieder ganzen Tag, ich mache Dienstag alle zwei Wochen nichts, wirklich gar nichts.
Ich gehe auf die Arbeit und ab 9.30 Uhr geht es los mit Daily und Retrospektive und Review und Planning
und das Ganze geht offiziell, glaube ich, bis 16.30 Uhr oder gar 17 Uhr, aber ich haue immer 16.00 Uhr, 16.05 Uhr ab.
Jetzt wissen die auch alle schon, 16.05 Uhr bin ich weg.
Apple TV, iPad, ja.
Ich denke, es ist tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll, bei solchen Sachen ein bisschen die Lehre mit einzubeziehen, was ihr,
sagen wir mal, präferiertes System ist.
Also, dementsprechend müssen die auch mal ein bisschen was ausprobieren.
Es hat nämlich meistens keinen Sinn, wenn man Lösungen und Techniken und Software und Hardware und generell IT-Lösungen einführt,
so komplett 90, so hoch,
zu 180 Grad entgegen dem, was die Leute sich wünschen oder was sie gerne hätten.
Das klappt meistens nicht, dann wird es auch meistens nicht richtig benutzt.
Hast du Tipps, um deine Ausbildungsvergütung hochzuhandeln?
Ganz ehrlich, nee, aber mach dir mal nicht so viel Gedanken um deine Ausbildungsvergütung.
Das hält ja nicht so lang.
Mach dir lieber Gedanken darum, wie du danach ordentlich Kohle bekommst.
Du musst nämlich nicht zwangsläufig da bleiben.
Also, hör dich da ruhig schon mal frühzeitig um, was du sonst noch für Optionen hast,
anstatt dort zu bleiben, wo du deine Ausbildung machst.
Dann hast du nämlich eine ganz andere Verhandlungsbasis am Ende der Ausbildung.
So, Ausbildungsvergütung hochhandeln, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir, also,
die wenigsten Unternehmen werden das machen.
Die haben wahrscheinlich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es Tarifverträge für sowas gibt,
die haben wahrscheinlich ein festgelegtes Ding, was jeder Azubi kriegt.
Und es ist jetzt ja auch nicht, als könntest du irgendwie großartig,
da, weil, du, als hättest du irgendwie, irgendwie ein Druckmittel,
beziehungsweise als hättest du irgendwie was, was, weil, ich meine, hey, du kannst sagen,
ja, wenn ich nicht mehr Geld kriege, dann hau ich ab.
Dann sag ich, ja gut, pff, juckt uns doch nicht.
Also, insofern, also, das, ich glaube, da würde ich mir nicht so viele Gedanken zu machen.
Guck lieber, dass du danach ordentlich was rausgehandelt kriegst.
Ich meine, sicherlich kann man, pff, Fragen kosten nichts.
Und denen gute Argumente bringen.
Weil, Azubi, du bist sicherlich auch, aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass ich da viel tun wird.
Danach hast du eine deutlich bessere Verhandlungsbasis, wenn du dich ein bisschen umgeguckt hast.
Also, benutze lieber die Zeit jetzt, wenn du, sagen wir mal, ein dreiviertel Jahr oder so
vor Ende der Ausbildung bist, guck dich doch, guck dich ruhig schon mal um.
Dass du so ungefähr weißt, was bei euch in der Region, beziehungsweise in der Branche da angesagt ist
und was du noch für Optionen hast.
Kann man das nicht in den Values setzen?
Doch, kannst du.
Du kannst überschreiben, das funktioniert.
Aber du willst ja nicht jede einzelne Imageversion.
Das Ding besteht aus, was weiß ich, 15 verschiedenen Images.
Willst du denn alle überschreiben?
Also, sowas muss out of the box funktionieren.
Bist du eigentlich anerkannter IHK-Ausbilder?
Ne, bin ich nicht.
Ja, habe ich gemacht, aber ich war nie anerkannter IHK-Ausbilder.
Also, ich bin kein anerkannter IHK-Ausbilder.
Ich muss demnächst IHK-Ausbilderprüfung machen.
Echt, was muss man da so machen?
Was kommt denn da so dran?
Ist die IHK-Ausbilderprüfung schwer?
Ist die IHK-Ausbildung und...
Warum kürzen wir jeden Kack ab, Mann?
Wir haben einen Scrum Master, ja.
Der war jetzt aber drei Wochen im Urlaub.
Ich glaube, der ist nächste Woche wieder da.
Eigentlich würde man dann sagen, der reinen Lehre nach geht das ja gar nicht.
Du kannst ja keinen Scrum machen ohne Scrum Master und so.
Doch, das funktioniert.
Wenn die Leute nicht vorhaben, sich abzufacken gegenseitig, funktioniert das.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Es muss einfach passen zu dem, was man macht.
Es hat keinen Sinn, quasi agil zu sein, nur um nach irgendeinem gewissen Schema agil zu sein.
Sondern es muss ja unterm Strich auch was bringen.
Und auch passen.
Wie viel bekommst du denn?
Also...
Ist das...
Ich meine, als Azubi musst du eh nicht so viel Steuern bezahlen.
Also wahrscheinlich ist das, was du insgesamt brutto bekommst, wahrscheinlich nicht so viel höher.
Ja, das ist natürlich schon nicht viel.
Also ich habe letztens irgendwo gesehen, glaube ich, bei der Telekom oder so.
Da habe ich irgendeinen Azubi gesehen im dritten Jahr oder so.
Da hat auch, glaube ich, hier jemand geschrieben, der bekommt 1400 Euro oder sowas.
Ausbildungsvergütung.
Also das ist schon wirklich wenig.
Also ich glaube, ich habe auch nicht so viel mehr bekommen damals, muss ich sagen.
Allerdings war das halt 2007.
Ich habe dann am Ende auch irgendwie, was weiß ich, 1000 Euro oder so gekriegt.
Ja, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Aha.
Das heißt, es gibt dann Prüfungs-Azubis.
Ich habe meine Ausbildung nicht verkürzt, Leute.
Wisst ihr, was der Grund ist, warum ich meine Ausbildung nicht verkürzt habe?
Jetzt geht mal in euch, ihr kennt mich.
Warum habe ich meine Ausbildung nicht verkürzt?
Dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Ich hatte keinen Bock.
Ich habe mir gedacht, soll ich jetzt ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr...
Wenn ich verkürze...
Warum soll ich verkürzen?
Ich kann jetzt noch ein Jahr hier abgammeln.
Berufsschule ist für den Arsch.
Musst nichts für machen.
Auf der Arbeit musst du auch nichts machen.
Wenn ich gerade...
Ich konnte einfach noch ein Jahr mehr abgammeln.
Warum hätte ich das nicht machen sollen?
Das würde ich aber nur im äußersten Notfall machen.
Wenn der Rest ganz gut ist, würde ich die Ausbildung versuchen durchzuhalten und dann halt woanders hin.
Die sind dann bestimmt danach auch knauserig.
Dass du noch während der Ausbildung guckst, was du für Optionen hast.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, Fragen...
Fragen kosten nichts.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, weil...
Wahrscheinlich werden die anderen dann auch so viel...
So wenig kriegen.
Aber...
Ich werde dich nicht rausschmeißen.
Wenn du ihn fragst.
Ganz davon abgesehen, einer der riesen Vorteile als Azubi ist, du kannst Azubis nicht rausschmeißen.
Es sei denn...
Die klauen...
Die klauen Hardware oder so.
Moin, Chainlord.
Hast du die Webseite?
Nein.
Noch lange nicht.
Wir haben da insgesamt vielleicht 4-5 Stunden dran gearbeitet.
Das ist vielleicht zur Hälfte fertig.
Wie lange hast du denn noch?
Chili... Irgendwas mit...
Chili Bambili.
Wie lange hast du noch Ausbildung?
Jetzt im zweiten?
Ja.
Dann hast du es doch fast hinter dir.
Jetzt im zweiten?
Ja.
Jetzt im zweiten Jahr heißt...
Ah, jetzt im zweiten Jahr.
Das heißt, das zweite Jahr hat jetzt angefangen.
Gerade erst, oder? Wie ist das?
Weil meistens ist das ja so in dem Dreh hier.
Ja.
Ja, gut. Da hast du...
Da hast du im Endeffekt erst ein Jahr rum.
Ja.
Gut, vielleicht kannst du ja verkürzen.
Aber ich würde auf jeden Fall die Zeit nutzen, Know-How aufzubauen, was einem später Kohle bringt.
Weil wenn du keine Ahnung hast, nur weil du Fisi bist, bringt es dir das auch nicht.
Die Ausbildung ist nicht das, was dir letztendlich den Job bringt, beziehungsweise ein ordentliches Gehalt bringt,
sondern das, was du gelernt hast, beziehungsweise musst du nicht mal unbedingt in der Ausbildung lernen,
was du halt weißt zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Und am besten halt irgendwas, was auch halbwegs, halbwegs beliebt ist.
Also zum Beispiel Kobol-Entwickler.
Am besten was, was dir gefällt.
Ohne Scheiß, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Am besten ist was, ihr kennt euch in einem Gebiet aus, das euch gefällt, das euch Spaß macht.
Weil dann werdet ihr auch immer besser, dann fällt euch Lernen nicht so schwer.
Und ihr habt eine höhere Chance darin zu arbeiten und noch besser zu werden.
Also es ist wirklich sehr sinnvoll, sich auf was zu konzentrieren, was einem gefällt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Können wir machen. Können wir machen.
Ich habe 7TV Emote Slots, gibt es ja tausende irgendwie.
Sinnvolle Zertifikate im Kubernetes Umfeld weiß ich nicht.
Also auf Reddit, im Kubernetes Subreddit sind gefühlt die Hälfte der Fragen, wie man sein, frag mich nicht, wie dieses heißt, dieses Kubernetes Certified Ding macht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das so sinnig ist, ob man das unbedingt braucht.
Also ich mache aktuell auch zu 90% nur Kubernetes und Google Cloud Geschichten.
Aber ich habe kein Zertifikat und kriege trotzdem Geld dafür.
Also insofern.
Das hatten wir heute schon.
Das hatten wir, das hatten wir heute schon.
Da warst du noch nicht da, Chainlord.
Es gibt, bevor es den Rust Rewrite gibt, gibt es den C++ Rewrite.
Oh doch, Leute, ich kann euch noch was zeigen.
Wisst ihr, was ich, was ich, wisst ihr, was ich, was ich vorhin oder was heißt vorhin, was ich letztens gelernt habe?
Und zwar.
Wir schreiben jetzt mal etwas Pseudo C++.
Nur zwei Zeilen.
Macht euch keine, keine Sorgen.
Ja.
touchmain.cpp.
Ich hoffe, das geht so.
So, ich will euch mal, ich will euch mal was fragen, was, was ihr denkt, was ihr denkt.
Yes, I trust the author.
Ja, ja, ich truste den Docker.
Nein.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich standardmäßig Auto komplett?
Ja, install, install die C++ Extension.
Beste.
Proprietäre Microsoft Shit drinne.
So.
Also, passt, passt mal auf.
Ähm.
So.
Was meint ihr?
Was?
So.
Äh.
Auto, Vector, ey, C++, Alter.
Standard.
Äh.
Warum ist da nichts drin?
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen?
So.
Ah, nee, ich muss das ja noch includen, ne?
Include.
Vector.
So, hä?
Ging das so?
Vector. So, passt mal auf.
So.
Ähm. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Äh, das ist falsch, was ich mache.
Ist falsch, falsch, falsch.
Und dann mal anders. Was meint...
Monke es.
Was meint ihr, welcher,
welcher Typ
i ist jetzt?
Man kann es davon ab...
Hahaha. Also.
Ähm, was meint ihr, was meint ihr,
welcher Datentyp,
was meint ihr, welcher Datentyp
i ist?
Ist das ein int? Ist das ein bool?
Also, man würde, man würde vermuten,
man würde vermuten,
das geht, oder?
Man würde, man würde, also,
also, man würde, würde eigentlich vermuten,
dass, das würde jetzt, das geht jetzt, ne?
Ähm, machen wir mal.
Moment. Ich, ich zeige euch das. Passt mal auf.
Es wird, es wird besser. Push.
Ja, true. True.
Lul weh. So.
Und, Moment. Wie, wie macht man das jetzt?
Wie macht man eine ordentliche Ausgabe in
C++ jetzt, ähm,
Standardformat?
Ne. Ach, du Scheiße, man.
C++ aus dem Kopf, alter.
Ne,
cout ist, ist, ist das Noobzeug.
Das verwendet keiner mehr.
Die, die machen doch jetzt, warte mal.
Standardformat print.
Machen die doch jetzt. Gibt doch jetzt.
Gibt doch, gibt doch neu.
Macht doch, macht doch keiner mehr.
Macht doch keiner mehr.
Cout. Oder doch?
Ist egal.
Ich versuche das mal zu kompilieren.
Mal gucken, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Jetzt ist natürlich die große
Preisfrage. GCC.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
GCC, GCC compile file.
Keine Ahnung, wie das überhaupt funktioniert aus dem Kopf.
Oder, ne.
G++ ist es, oder?
G++.
G++ compile file. Da muss man ja sagen, irgendwie
in. Ich tue nicht so.
Ich weiß es einfach nicht.
Wer weiß denn so was aus dem Kopf?
So, äh, main cpp.
Ach so, ja gut.
Ich muss das, muss das wahrscheinlich ausgeben. Moment.
Include, include.
Was?
Stream muss man, oder?
Stream. Ist es nicht stream,
dass man dann was ausgeben kann?
Fuckin hell, Alter. Ich will einfach was ausgeben.
I host streamer.
C++ standard out.
I host stream?
Okay.
Standard
value.
Value. So.
Und jetzt machen wir noch hier
ein new line. Okay.
Funktioniert das jetzt?
Okay, es hat kompiliert und
es funktioniert.
Nicht. Tja.
Es ist
ne 1. Warum ist das ne 1?
Warum ist das ne 1?
Weil true. Also,
es ist jetzt was anderes, als ich erwartet habe,
ehrlich gesagt. Aber,
worauf ich eigentlich raus will,
ich hab eigentlich gedacht, es gibt nen Compiler-Fehler,
aber gibt es nicht. Ähm.
Also,
worauf ich, worauf ich raus will,
ist folgendes.
Wir könnten, wir probieren das mal anders aus.
Moment. Vielleicht, vielleicht ist, ist der
iterator einfach so schlau.
Okay, das müsste auch funktionieren,
oder?
Chatge. Ah, Compiler.
Ah, ne, ne, Moment. Nicht value. Vector.
Okay, das, das funktioniert.
Das ist ne 1.
Okay. So, warte mal.
Ich muss das jetzt mal testen, weil vielleicht
ist es in GCC auch gar nicht mehr
so, wie ich das denke.
Tatsächlich, das funktioniert.
Anscheinend haben sie das geändert.
Anscheinend haben sie das
geändert, weil
ich hab heute nen Artikel darüber gelesen,
dass
StandardVector
kein StandardVector ist. Äh,
StandardVectorBool kein StandardVector ist.
Also wer jetzt denkt,
dass zum Beispiel
StandardVectorBool
das gleiche wäre, wie
StandardVectorChar, der hat
verloren. Das ist nicht so.
Ein StandardVectorBool
ist kein StandardVector,
sondern ein int,
wo einzelne Bits
gesetzt werden. Leider
konnte ich
euch das jetzt nicht zeigen. Vielleicht haben sie das
geändert. Vielleicht ist das
jetzt anders.
Why does, why does
StandardVector have no data?
Äh, interessant.
Siehst du mal. Ich, ich dachte
nämlich eigentlich, dass
ein Index,
ja Moment, was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich?
Was,
was ist denn das jetzt
eigentlich für nen
StandardVectorBool?
Es ist ein, es ist kein
Bool, was da rauskommt. Ja, das ist auch schon mal sehr merkwürdig.
Und
geht add
an der Stelle?
Ah, scheint alles zu funktionieren. Also,
anscheinend, anscheinend hat sich das
ein bisschen geändert zu dem, was ich heute
gelesen hat. Zumindest
den Artikel, den ich
darüber gelesen habe, ist, dass
außer StandardBool
sich alle Vector
generic, mit was auch immer
du da reinstöpseln kannst,
normal verhalten, aber
StandardBoolVector eine eigene
Klasse ist, die keine
Bools in den Vector schreibt, sondern
aus Performance und
Platzgründen optimiert, das
auf nen Int mappt. Auf die einzelnen
Bits von nem Int.
Was sicherlich ne coole Sache ist, aber blöd
es StandardVector zu nennen,
wenn man doch, wenn man
sich doch anders verhält, wie alle anderen Typen
da drinne. Guck, man sieht
hier auch, man sieht hier auch die, die ganzen
Einträge von...
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie da was dran
geändert haben, nachdem die, also
als ich den Artikel gelesen hab,
war ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher, dass ein
Index darauf nicht
gehen dürfte, wobei man halt
ja auch hier sieht, es kommt ja da auch
gar kein Bool raus, so
wirklich, ja? Also, könnte
ich denn jetzt, könnte ich denn jetzt überhaupt
sowas sagen, wie value gleich gleich
true? Wir machen das so, ich weiß, man muss das noch nicht
schreiben, aber ich will mal ausprobieren, ob das, ob das
funktioniert, ob der
jetzt compile, nee, das kompiliert,
okay, das ist, das funktioniert, ja.
Das...
Ja gut, aber C, bei C
gibt es ja gar keinen Bool im eigentlichen Sinne,
ne? Also du kannst da noch ne 1
reinstecken, das ist auch okay.
Aber es ist ein StandardVectorBoolReferenceValue.
...
Sehr weirdchamp
alles, ähm, interessant.
Siehste, entweder
hab ich den Artikel nicht ganz verstanden, oder
oder da haben's mittlerweile ein bisschen
bisschen besser
gemacht. Was macht ein Auto
in C++? Normalerweise
würde ich sagen, so wie
war in C Sharp, aber nachdem
es C++ ist, bin ich mir
nicht wirklich sicher, ob das der Fall ist.
Weil,
du kannst in C++ auch sowas
hier machen, was ich super, super
mega weird finde.
Du kannst ein AutoReturnType
haben, okay,
bei main funktioniert das anscheinend nicht,
aber du kannst AutoReturnType
haben. Warum kann main kein AutoReturnType
haben?
Egal, ich will das gar nicht verstehen
müssen.
Wir lassen's, wir lassen's jetzt einfach gut sein.
Ich will, ich will's gar nicht, gar nicht
verstehen. Naja, gut.
Dann, dann war der Effekt jetzt
leider nicht so gut, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Ich hab gedacht, ich kann euch jetzt zeigen,
an der Stelle, guck mal, da denkt ihr,
es kommt nen Bool raus, und es kommt kein Bool. Es kommt ja auch
kein Bool raus, und das geht nicht.
AutoReturn sollte eigentlich nicht
gehen. Doch, oder?
Das ist doch, das geht doch, ja. AutoReturn
C++, doch, doch,
das funktioniert.
Guck da.
Ganz, ganz offiziell geht das.
Oder, oder muss das nur in, oder geht das nur in nem
Template? Wobei, was
hat das Template mit meinem...
Aber das ergibt keinen Sinn. Warum kann
ich nicht einfach A hinschreiben, oder B?
Moment, was ist das denn
jetzt schon wieder? Was ist
StandardBoolAlpha?
Was zum...
What?
Also, es gibt immer
C++-Typen
und so, wo ich
noch nie was von gehört hab.
Wo war ich denn jetzt hier eben drinne?
Hier. Ach, Repos.
Temp C++.
Hä? Da kommt jetzt nix raus?
Bool, was?
Muss man da jetzt, muss man da
jetzt Value reinstecken, oder?
Nee. Keine Ahnung. Ich, ich
will's nicht verstehen. Mir wurscht.
Outdated, overrated,
kein C++ mehr jetzt, ey.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal das... Wenn wir grad schon mal schön
Programmiersprachen sind, Leute.
Lasst uns doch mal das PHP-Video angucken
jetzt.
Also, eines der, eines der
ekligsten Sachen in C++, finde ich, ist immer
noch diese, diese
chronodatetime-API, die sie da
haben. So,
kaste Millisekunden in Sekunden und so was.
Dann lasst uns doch mal
schauen, was an PHP so geil ist.
PHP doesn't
suck anymore.
Ich glaube ihm sogar, dass die Sprache an sich
gar nicht mehr suckt, aber mir hat das Ökosystem
überhaupt nicht zugesagt, das letzte Mal.
Ich kann mich nur noch dunkel dran erinnern,
was mich... Also,
wir haben Laravel probiert, letztens
in nem Stream. Ist schon ne Weile her.
Und ich
wollte irgendein
zusätzliches
Package installieren.
Ich glaube, um ein
Bild zu rotaten oder so was.
Irgendein Image-Tool für PNGs.
Und
das war super weird, das zu
registrieren, dass das überhaupt benutzt wird.
Ja, gucken wir mal. Also,
was, was erzählt der uns? 10 Minuten, das
kriegen wir.
Kotlin-Ökosystem vs. PHP.
Ja, den Maven-Kram fand ich
auch abartig, letztens. Ich versteh...
Ganz ehrlich, ich versteh gar nicht, wie
kann das einfach 2023
immer noch... Wobei, also,
IntelliJ hat das schon ganz gut
gemacht. Also, wenn man's
einmal hinzugefügt hat, war das auch nicht
so viel schlechter als Nougat.
Aus irgendeinem Grund...
Cradle konnten wir nicht verwenden, weil das meine
Java-Version nicht unterstützt hat.
Irgendwas war da. Ich wollte das verwenden,
das ging aber nicht. Als wir letztens ein bisschen
Kotlin-Zeug gebastelt haben.
Und das
war schon Painstamp, aber ich versteh's im Jahr
2023 gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie das sein kann...
Wenn man sich Sprachen
anguckt, wie Rust zum Beispiel.
Jetzt können wir wirklich mal Rust
positiv erwähnen, auch wenn ich Rust ganz gerne
mal flame, aber in dem Punkt ist Rust wirklich
gut. Rust hat ein eingebautes
Package-Manager-Tool,
was gescheit funktioniert.
Hat eine halbwegs übersichtliche
Config für die
Projekte.
Und hat das halt alles built-in.
Hat ein Testing-Tool standardmäßig dabei.
Und...
Das funktioniert einfach. Ruby hat das
seit 10 plus...
Oder seit Anfang an schon.
Ruby gibt's seit 2003.
Und seit 20 Jahren hat Ruby einen ordentlichen Package-Manager.
Damals noch richtig was Neues.
Und in C++ hantieren
die Leute mit Header-Files.
Und in Java hantieren sie mit irgendwelchen
manuellen Bild-Dingern.
Scripts.
Es geht immer noch schlimmer.
Header-Files und CMake zusammen.
Aber wie kann es sein,
dass God of the World
hinzugefügt wird
in den C++-Standard,
aber keiner auf die Idee kommt,
wie wär's mal mit einem offiziellen, sinnvollen
Package-Manager?
Ich mein, da sind bestimmt schon Leute
auf die Idee gekommen, aber dann wurde das bestimmt wieder
total zerdiskutiert
von
den C++-Gremiumsleuten.
Composer
war das bei...
PAP?
Ne, bei Laravel war das Artisan
oder sowas.
Ja, das ist aber auch alles so
halboffizielles Zeug, das von Microsoft
vielleicht in dem Ökosystem recht verbreitet.
Warum gibt es keinen offiziellen
Package-Manager? Da versteht man nicht.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal anschauen.
Ich mein, seriously, Header-Files
in 2023, Alter.
So, mal gucken, warum PAP geil ist.
Oh, was?
Rust is the future!
Na, die Rust-Taskforce
ist auch schon bei ihm am Start
unter den Videos.
PHP, haha, what a joke!
PHP is slow, very slow.
In fact, it's four times
slower than .NET.
Da wär ich mir gar nicht
mal so sicher. .NET ist schon halbwegs
geschwind, ordentlich programmiert,
aber ich glaube,
bei normalen, bei so diesen
Standardsachen, wenn man jetzt vielleicht mal weg
von irgendwelchen optimierten
Multi-Threading und C-Interop-Sachen
geht, ich glaube,
so langsam ist PHP gar nicht.
Wenn man sich Benchmarks anguckt,
ist PHP noch eine ganze, ganze Ecke
vor Python und Ruby und sowas.
Also, so schlecht
ist PHP für die Performance gar nicht.
PHP is dead. PHP sucks. All the time.
Every time. And most of the people
that think PHP is dead haven't
looked at PHP since like
2012, which is before 5.4
came out. Ist das ein Greenscreen
hinter ihm? Der hat
so, nee, das ist einfach Licht, was ihn von hinten
anscheinend, was ein bisschen
so ein Outline gibt.
And listen, things were a lot different in
2012. I had just graduated college
with a degree in accounting
for some reason. This guy
was still the president over here.
This movie... Also, das Beste an
Obama,
fand ich sein Echsenmensch-Bodyguard.
Falls jemand das Revealed-Video
kennt dazu.
...was still the president over here.
This movie was in theaters and honestly,
pretty good movie. Our music
went through this real weird
hey-ho phase, where we were always
shouting hey-ho in the songs.
Toss. Ist das Toss?
So I think it's safe
to say that a lot has changed
since 2012. Video ist leise?
Das ist volle Pulle.
PHP no longer sucks. Ich glaube, das Video
ist einfach leise aufgenommen von ihm.
...run you through a bunch of the language changes
that have happened since around
2012, when PHP 5.4 came out.
And stick around to the very end,
because we're gonna talk about types.
We gotta talk about type safety. Every time
I talk about PHP, people just say,
yeah, I just need types. We gotta have types.
What about types? Do you guys have types?
I can't leave my types. We've got types.
So I'm gonna show you all the...
Hat PHP types?
Letztes Mal, wo ich mit PHP
ein bisschen was gemacht, das war zu Zeiten, wo ich
Battlefield-4-Server hatte.
Ich glaube, damals war das noch alles dynamisch.
Aber
letztens in Laravel, da hatten wir schon
Types, glaube ich. Ich bin mir da
gar nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
...the different types you can do at the end.
Let's take a look at these changes.
Going all the way back to 2012 for this one,
PHP 5.4 included traits.
So instead of writing the same
method body over and over and over...
Das ist tatsächlich cool.
Das ist ein Feature,
das hätte ich
first class support,
sowas in der Richtung, hätte ich
gerne in C-Sharp auch. Es gibt
sowas ähnliches mittlerweile.
Also Interfaces gibt es ja in C-Sharp
schon ewig, aber
Interfaces konnten halt lange Zeit
keine Logik mitbringen.
Mittlerweile können Interfaces Logik
mitbringen. Also du
kannst sowas in C-Sharp
mittlerweile auch machen mit
Interfaces und Default
Implementations.
Aber ich weiß
nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert wie in dem Fall
mit PHP. Ich find's eine coole
Idee. Das ist halt nicht...
objektorientierte Vererbungssachen,
sondern mehr so
add-in-mäßig.
Rust kann das ja auch. Go glaub ich
auch.
Or instead of abusing inheritance,
we now have composition, so you can have
traits and include those in every class
favoring composition over
inheritance.
Short array syntax. Imagine
writing out the word
array like a caveman.
So schlimm find ich das jetzt nicht.
When you can just use square brackets.
Short array syntax allows you to use
square brackets. Thank you very much.
Okay, ja.
Das ist natürlich viel besser.
Das sieht halt aus
wie in der normalen
von Menschen benutzbare
Programmiersprache.
Ecke geklammern, array. Gutes.
...destructuring. It used to be
that you would have to... Ich frage mich, ob
sie es in PHP backwards
compatibility mäßig
noch drinne
haben, dass du array schreiben kannst.
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Also,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie bei
PHP auch die ein oder anderen Sachen
breaking changes mäßig
rausgeschmissen
haben über die Jahre. Was, was
C++ sich ja komplett drückt davor,
das zu machen. To assign an array to a
temporary variable and then reference
those elements by index if you
wanted to assign them to other variables.
Now you can just use array
destructuring and directly assign
the variable... Ach ja, das
finde ich gut. Nice.
...now you can just use array destructuring...
Oh, ganz ehrlich, eigentlich auch
eine ganz brauchbare Syntax. Kann man sich gut
merken.
Das ganze Dollargedöns
in PHP finde ich halt ein bisschen affig.
Aber das war schon immer so. Das ist wahrscheinlich
was, was man auch so grundlegendes nicht so
easy ändern kann. Da hast du ja
Doppeldeutigkeiten dann in der Syntax drinnen.
...and directly assign
the variables from the array.
We have first class variadic functions,
so you can pass as many arguments to a
function as you want using this
...syntax.
Speaking of ...syntax, you can use that same
syntax to spread
or splat an array into an
argument list for a function call.
Nicht schlecht, auch gut. Leute,
ich habe fast den Eindruck, dass es
noch Sprachengremium und Standardmacher
gibt, die wissen, wie man das macht.
Okay, der Fairness halber würde ich sagen,
die meisten wissen eigentlich,
wie man das macht. Plus C++ weiß das nicht.
Wie schafft
man es, eine Sprache die letzten Jahre
über immer mehr zu verkacken
und unlogischer, inkonsistenter
zu machen? Und dann
guckt man zu anderen Sprachen rüber, wie PHP
in dem Fall sogar, und
da sieht man, guck da, es funktioniert.
Man muss sich nur die
C++ Lambda Syntax angucken.
Eckige Klammern und
dann noch eine Sache mit Reference Capturen
und Capturen und Auto Capturen
und Klammern
dahinter, Klammern nicht dahinter
und pfff, alter.
Wer sich das ausgedacht hat.
Habt ihr mal async await gesehen in C++?
Das ist so dermaßen
beschissen, das will keiner benutzen.
You can use
that same syntax to spread
or splat an array
into another array.
Auch nicht schlecht. Also,
und ich finde, eine Sache, ich hab
keine große Ahnung von PHP, ja,
aber ich finde, sie haben's
geschafft, sinnvolle
Syntax für
neue Funktionen zu finden,
die PHP-like
aussehen. Also,
es ist ja immer blöd, wenn man Konzepte
von anderen Sprachen klaut,
die dann aber komplett Alien-mäßig aussehen,
in der jeweiligen
Sprache. Aber ich finde, das sieht
irgendwie, ist ein sinnvolles Feature und
das sieht auch irgendwie nach PHP aus.
Ja, und das Punkt-pun-Punkt ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen keck JavaScript.
Wobei das in C-Sharp mittlerweile auch funktioniert.
So ähnlich, so ähnlich.
Ja, du kannst, wenn du Pattern-Matching
machst in C-Sharp, kannst
du mittlerweile auch sowas wie Punkt-Punkt
Rest vom Array und sowas verwenden.
Das geht mittlerweile.
If you want to take all the items from one array
and put it into a second array
Ob Perl auch die ganzen
Features mittlerweile hat?
Okay, you can do that with this spread operator.
We now have generators.
If you want to do something memory in
Moment, das ging früher in PHP nicht.
Intensive, but in a memory
efficient way, you can use
a generator. So if you need to read a huge
file, you don't have to load that whole
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, so wenige benutzen
PHP gar nicht. Klar, PHP
ist bei weitem nicht mehr das,
wenn du mal 20,
15 bis 20 Jahre
zurückguckst, wo eigentlich alles
an Web-Anwendungen in PHP war,
da waren die Zeiten aber auch anders.
Da waren die Leute auf irgendwelchen
Billig-Web-Hostern, da gab es kein
Ich starte mal kurz einen Container in der Cloud.
Ich biete mir mal kurz einen Linux-Server mal
in den Domain in 30, das hat mit PHP
nichts zu tun. Da gab es billigen
Billigen Web-Hosting, Web-Space
mit PHP und MySQL
und es gab nicht
viele Alternativen, aber
trotzdem, ich glaube, so wenig
verbreitet ist PHP gar nicht mal.
Und gut Ding braucht Weile, was
Sprachenstandards angeht. Ich
kann verstehen, dass sie das nicht vor 10
Jahren alles hinbekommen haben.
Ich meine, du musst das irgendwie
sinnig, es kann natürlich auch sein,
dass sie es vor 10 Jahren noch nicht wollten,
dann könnte man zu Recht sagen, hätten sie es mal
hingekriegt.
Aber
ich meine, Negativ-Beispiel ist
C++, die haben ganz
viel Zeug die letzten 10 Jahre neu
hinzugefügt in den Standard, aber
fast nichts davon ist sinnvoll,
implementiert
über die Compiler hinweg, also
also
in der Gänze implementiert,
also es ist sehr viel
halbherzig implementiert, dazu
kommt, dass der Standard selbst total
uneinheitlich
ist. Mal werden Sachen so benutzt,
mal werden Sachen so benutzt, da gibt
es irgendwelche Typen im Standard, die
in 1% der Fällen benutzbar
sind, also sehr sehr wirr.
Also C++ ist das
beste Beispiel dafür, wie man eine
eh schon hässliche Sprache noch weit
verunstalten kann, mit eigentlich
sinnvollen Features, aber nicht gut
durchdacht.
Warum hat C++
denn ganz viele Compiler? Ich würde sagen,
es ist wahrscheinlich historisch entstanden,
weil es gibt ja keine
wirklich offizielle C++-Implementierung.
Das offiziellste,
was es gibt, ist wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile
GCC ist es nicht, ist
wahrscheinlich
Clang, wie das die C++-Leute
aussprechen, also das LLV...
LLVM? Ne, wie heißt
das Ding?
LVM heißt das, gell?
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch das offiziellste,
was es gibt. Es gibt keinen offiziellen C++-Compiler.
Und dementsprechend
ist das alles so...
Ja, Microsoft hat dann wieder ihren eigenen
Krempel gemacht.
Ich mein,
C++ unterstützt halt
dadurch enorm viele Plattformen.
Das ist schon ein Vorteil. Es gibt für jede
hast du nicht gesehen
dahergelaufene Architektur C++
Compiler,
ja, für
ESP32, den programmierst du hauptsächlich
in C und C++.
Also,
es krankt aber, denke ich,
schon ein bisschen daran, auch, dass es keine
offizielle Implementierung gibt. Weil eine
offizielle Implementierung hätte den riesen
Vorteil, dass es weniger
undefined Behaviour gibt. Da wird nämlich einfach
schlechtergreifend defined, wie das Behaviour
sein soll. Das Behaviour ist, so wie sich
die Referenzimplementierung verhält. Ganz einfach.
Selbst wenn es nicht direkt
im Standard in allen Fällen
erfasst ist, so wie sich die offizielle
Referenzimplementierung verhält, ist halt dann...
So muss es halt sein.
Und C++ strotzt ja vor undefined
Behaviour.
Also, das ist wirklich
ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie man
eine eh schon eklige Sprache
mit eigentlich sinnvollen Features
noch verwirrender und ekliger
machen kann, wenn man sich nicht richtig
durchdenkt. C++
die letzten 10 Jahre.
Ja, und das
wundert mich, dass C++,
äh, nee, sorry, das PHP
so lange keine... Wie nennt man
das? Wie heißt denn das
eigentlich?
Das ist ja... Ja, das ist im Prinzip
eine Schleife, die unterbrochen wird. Wie heißt
denn das korrekt? Wie man das nennt?
Alter, auf Deutsch!
Ah! Warum ist die
fucking Seite auf Deutsch?
Enumeraten.
Generator.
Ja, das trifft's wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Genau. Ja, Generator.
Generator. Ja.
Ich glaub, das... Generator
Function, ja. Das ist das meine...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was der offizielle Name
dafür ist. Also sprich, dass wenn du das hier
aufrufst, bekommst du immer eins
raus. Beim nächsten Aufruf noch eins,
dann noch eins, dann noch eins, ohne dass es
hängt.
Das ist halt eigentlich ganz cool.
Verwendet man recht selten, aber wenn man's
braucht, ist nice, dass es das gibt.
... generator to yield it
line by line by line. If you ever
need a new class but can't be bothered
to make a new file who has the time,
you can create an anonymous
class. An anonymous class can implement
an interface just like every other class.
Ah, das ist... ist das die PHP
Version von extension
methods?
New class implement... das ist
so ein bisschen wie extension methods,
nur vielleicht ein bisschen ekligere
Syntax. So das mit diesem
Filebar-PHP finde ich auch immer eklig.
Ja, das haben Sie sich wahrscheinlich von
C++ abgeguckt. Aber warum
nicht einfach einen Punkt?
So ein Punkt ist einfach deutlich nicer
als so ein File. Und mich würde nicht
wundern, wenn ein Punkt...
... wenn ein Punkt nicht
sogar in einer ordentlichen IDE translated
wird zu einem File.
In C++ gibt's einen Punkt, der...
Gut, in C-Style-Sprachen macht's
ja auch einen Sinn, warum's ein Punkt
ist, beziehungsweise ein...
... File.
File ist Pointer-D-Referenz...
also Pointer-D-Referenzieren
und dann auf den Inhalt zugreifen.
Und Punkt ist quasi direkt
auf eine
Stack-Variable
Inhalt zugreifen, ohne
D-Referenzieren. In C++,
in C-Kontext, wo man Pointer
und nicht Pointer und so hat, da macht es Sinn.
In C-Sharp gibt es
das ja prinzipiell auch.
Alle Objects sind Referenzen und alle
primitiven Sachen sind
Values, wobei das halt die Sprache
beziehungsweise die Runtime für dich unter der Haube
händelt und da brauchst
du auch nur noch einen Punkt. Wo du's
in C-Sharp auch brauchst, ist wenn du
unsave-code verwendest, dann brauchst du auch diesen File.
Ja.
Ja, wobei ich mir bei Go immer nie ganz sicher
bin, ob ich's
richtig mache mit den Pointern.
In C++ auch nicht.
Also das
ist sowas wie Extension-Message.
Das finde ich eigentlich eine gute Sache, dass PHP
das hat. Also...
Was bin ich hier
überhaupt sehend?
Moment, hä?
Ne, Moment.
Hä? Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Das sind keine Extension-Methods,
das sind...
Was ist das?
Okay, das ist eine Klasse, die keinen
Namen hat, in dem Sinn. Aber...
Also da verstehe
ich den Sinn davon ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Warum kann man nicht oben
einfach drüber schreiben?
Okay, doch, ich verstehe es.
Das macht... Wenn...
Okay, das macht Sinn,
wenn viele Libraries und Standards
Sachen eben
Interfaces erwarten
und
du oftmals nur eine Funktion
da drin brauchst und
das nur an einer Stelle benutzt,
dann macht's vielleicht der Bequemlichkeit
halber nicht so viel Sinn, da ist es eine extra
Klasse. Aber das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, okay,
das hätt's vielleicht auch nicht gebraucht. Aber dazu
muss man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen in PHP drin sein,
dass man das besser einordnen kann, wie sinnvoll.
Ich finde es erstmal nicht so schlimm,
einfach eine Klasse anzulegen,
dafür so viel...
Du hast ja hier schon mehr oder weniger alles.
Würdest du einfach noch zwei Klammern drumherum machen
und dem Ding einen Namen geben, dann wär's fertig
und wird auch nicht so viel größer. Aber...
Ja, okay. Ich hab erst gedacht,
das ist so was wie Extension Methods, ist es aber nicht.
One stupid little implementation,
but you don't want to make a full
class for it. This is a
big one. I need you to pay very, very
close attention. We now have... BIG!
...trailing commas in
function calls, so look very
closely at e-mail. Look at the very
end of the word e-mail and watch
what's about to happen.
Amazing.
No! No!
God, please, no! No!
Das ist ein bescheuer, das
Feature.
Das soll gefälligst ein Syntaxfehler sein,
wenn du da hinten ein Komma hast.
Was ist der Sinn
von einem Komma in einem
Funktionsaufruf, wenn kein
weiterer Parameter kommt?
Das ist doch komplett bescheuert,
warum ist das erlaubt? Hat irgendeiner
einen Plan, was der Sinn in PHP
davon ist? Das ist ein
Funktionsaufruf von
Compact.
So,
erster Parameter, zweiter Parameter,
dritter Parameter gibt's nicht.
Das soll einen Syntaxfehler geben. Wo ist
der Sinn davon? Ich versteh's nicht.
Das ist eher was,
was ich nicht haben
wollte. Das ist ja kein
Python hier oder sowas, ne?
Amazing, we now have trailing
commas in method calls, PHP
rules. Versteh ich nicht den Sinn.
This one's for all my Javascript friends. I know
you love your arrow functions. Well,
look out, friends. Moment, irgendwie
ist's grad auf einmal viel lauter geworden, oder?
Trailing commas
in method calls, PHP rules.
Ist das Video grad lauter geworden?
This one's for all my Javascript friends. I know
you love your arrow functions. Der Typ
ist lauter geworden auf einmal. Well, look
out, friends. We've got arrow functions,
too.
Da gucke mal an!
Es gibt ja noch tatsächlich Sprachdesigner,
die es schaffen, wenn
es jetzt vielleicht nicht superhübsch ist mit
FN, Dollar, User und sowas,
wenn nicht superhübsch, es gibt ja
Sprachdesigner, die es noch schaffen,
sowas halbwegs benutzbar zu gestalten.
Ich mein, habt ihr mal einen Lambda
Syntax in
in C++ gesehen?
Okay, das ist,
das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair, das ist ja nur die Beschreibung
davon, aber hey,
allein schon die Überschrift,
man.
C++ ist echt so eine
Sprache für alle, die auf
unleserliche Sonderzeichen
und so stehen.
Ah, fuck,
guckt euch das mal an!
Was ist das?
Das sieht aus, als hat einer
früher noch, bevor es Emojis gab, versucht,
irgendein U-Boot zu designen oder sowas.
guckt euch das an
Alter, ist das abartiger
Kack, was
in PHP können die Dinger nur
One-Liner sein, ja, das ist
doof, da hätte ich jetzt gedacht, du könntest
hat das einen Grund, warum die
ja, weil sie unfähig sind
weil die einfach als
Sprachdesigner komplett versagen
und sacken, also nicht nur
als Syntax und Language, auch
auch die Standard-Library ist
Kacke, ja, die sind einfach
unfähig oder werden sich nicht einig oder auch
keine Ahnung, das ist natürlich blöd, dass es in
PHP nur One-Line geht
ich glaube in Python
geht es auch nur One-Line
aber dort macht das auch kaum
einer, auch eine Sache, die mich
ein bisschen, wir haben ja letztens
so ein bisschen
ein kleines Add-on programmiert in Python
für meine, wir haben hier
diesen Wecker selbst programmiert
für meine
Leiste hier oben, den man resetten kann und
einstellen kann und so
das haben wir in Python programmiert
und das ist nicht lang, das sind irgendwie
150 Zeilen oder so, das ist nicht so viel
und
das hat mich auch immer irritiert, dass es
keine gescheiten Multi-Line
Lambda-Functions gibt
in Python, das ist alles so
One-Liner-Zeug, aber das ist irgendwie auch
verpönt bei den Python-Fans
ich weiß auch nicht so genau, warum
Rust ist auf jeden Fall
mega kryptisch zu lesen an vielen Stellen
da gebe ich dir recht, ja
deswegen bin ich auch kein so großer Rust-Fan
ehrlich gesagt, Rust hat sicherlich
unbestreitbar in manchen
Einsatz-Szenarien seinen Vorteil
ja, also Rust hat
finde ich, eigentlich
nur
an, also bei einer Kategorie
Software einen wirklichen, riesen Vorteil
und zwar, wenn du was haben
willst, was kompromisslos
Performance hat
und gleichzeitig
unsafe ist
also dass keine Manager
Sprache ist, kein Garbage-Collector
und nix, was aber trotz
der
Unsafe-ness
trotzdem so safe wie möglich ist
also, zum Beispiel
wenn man eine CSS-Engine
für einen Browser programmiert
dann ist Rust sicherlich
eine tolle Sache, du willst
dass das so sicher wie möglich ist
du möchtest so wenig wie möglich
die irgendwelche Overflows
Dangling-Pointer
Sachen dereferenzieren
einfangen
in einer Security-kritischen Anwendung
wie beispielsweise in einem CSS-Parser für einen Browser
so
das ist sinnvoll und du willst gleichzeitig
also das muss so safe
wie möglich, obwohl es unsafe ist
sein
und gleichzeitig möglichst schnell
so, dann ist Rust gut
für alles andere muss ich ehrlich
sagen, dadurch erkauft
man sich das mit Rust auch
zumindest mit einer meiner Meinung nach
deutlich erhöhten Entwicklerzeit im Vergleich
zu anderen Sprachen
ich weiß die Rust Taskforce und Rewrite
alles in Rust, die sieht das anders
die sagen hier, ich habe die komplette
Desktop-Anwendung mit UI
ich weiß nicht, wisst ihr, es gibt Rust-Fans
die sagen, ich habe OBS in drei Tagen
programmiert in Rust, Rewrite, Blazingly Fast
jetzt alles viel besser und sowas
glaube ich eben aber nicht
wenn das so ist
also, das müsste man mal
ausprobieren, aber
ich behaupte mal, dass
die allermeisten Entwickler in Rust deutlich
langsamer sind
was zu entwickeln als
in einer anderen Sprache
die sich halt dafür auch eignen würde
das heißt, Rust finde ich ist eigentlich nur genau
in diesem einen Punkt wirklich gut
und dafür ist es wahrscheinlich auch
die beste Sprache, die es gibt
aber für alles andere finde ich es Rust gar nicht so
sehr geeignet, zumal Rust sich auch
mega kryptisch schließt teilweise, Rust besteht
aus so viel, die haben gefühlt die komplette
Tastatur, die haben das
komplette so ASCII
Charset für
Sonderzeichen in Rust
verbraucht
fünf Insights vom Google Rust Journey
ok, wenn Google dazu was sagt
sag ich schon mal her
was sagt denn Google dazu
Rust
Rust takes more than six months
to learn debunked
ich glaube schon, dass man
relativ schnell, ich glaube das hat auch so
keiner gesagt, ich glaube schon, dass man relativ
schnell auch in Rust was auf die Reihe kriegt
aber bis man das komplett intus hat
das dauert,
länger als bei anderen sprachen und ich finde auch dass selbst gut programmiert
ist was das sieht man oftmals an beispielen von rastbrücken trotzdem
nicht so schön lesbar ist gerade weil das so viele sonderzeichen du hast ja
in rast denn ja auch noch zwischendrin im makros und alles also rast ist schon
nicht so nicht so ohne was angeht gut was der rast compiler macht mich jetzt
nicht
ach hier unsave ich glaube unsave und interop sollte
ganz gut gehen in rast rast has amazing compiler error messages das stimmt das
ist mir auch in rast aufgefallen ja also wenn man das mal mit dem c++ compiler
vergleicht rast zeigt dir relativ genau wo was kaputt ist ja das stimmt
ja ja das ist wirklich gut gucken wir mal php weiter doch hat rast
rast ist deutlich funktionaler als objektorientiert kann man mit rast
moderne uis erstellen ja es gibt die ein oder andere ui
frameworks wie voll featuret die sind weiß ich nicht habe ich noch nie
ausprobiert
das ist nice also wenn das so funktioniert wie in anderen sprachen dann
wird hier vorne geguckt ob das null ist
oder eventuell auch false,
wenn es JavaScript ist, ich glaube in JavaScript
könnte es auch false sein,
bin mir aber nicht sicher, vielleicht ist es auch nur undefined
und null in JavaScript, zumindest in C-Sharp
ist es so, das muss null sein, wenn das hier
null ist, dann wird das
benutzt, das benutzt man zum Beispiel
ganz gerne, um Default-Werte zu setzen,
Kurzschreibweise geht übrigens auch
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen
gleich,
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen gleich
geht glaube ich auch in vielen Sprachen.
Ah, soll ich doch.
Da wird man ja,
Leute, man bekommt ja
fast den Eindruck,
dass da an
PHP paar Language
Designer gesessen haben,
die was von ihrem Job
verstehen.
Also was, was C++
Entwickler anscheinend nicht gewöhnt sind.
Aber jetzt haben wir den
null-Chaining-Operator und wir können
einfach sagen, wenn Birthday nicht null ist,
dann nennen wir das Format-Functional.
Aha, okay, das haben die auch, man hat ja
fast den Eindruck, die haben sich von anderen
Sprachen was abgeguckt, was dort gut funktioniert
und haben es in PHP eingebaut,
auf einen durchdachten
PHP-Styling-Way.
Also da muss ich sagen,
das ist wirklich so, ich bin kein
großer PHP-Programmierer, aber das
klingt für mich alles sehr schlüssig
und auch von der Syntax her
sieht es sehr nach PHP aus,
aber trotzdem integriert mit
den guten Sachen, die sich in anderen
Sprachen bewährt haben. Also muss man sagen,
die wissen anscheinend wirklich, was sie so treiben.
If it is null, just stop the chain
right there. We have named
arguments now. It used to be
that if you wanted to skip over an optional argument,
you had to leave a null in the position
of that argument, but now we
can just name our arguments and pass them in any
order that we want. PHP has
attributes now, which in other languages
are probably called annotations,
but you can add an annotation
to a class or a method or an
argument or a property. You can add an annotation
to almost anything.
Das ist auch cool. Das ist das
mega nice, sowas.
...control a little bit of behavior that way.
Keep this in mind. We're gonna look at this again in a second.
This one is just a huge,
massive improvement. It used to be
when you were catching an exception,
you had to have a variable for that
exception, even if you weren't gonna use it.
Even if you were just simply gonna return false,
you had to have that little e in there.
Now, look at...
Okay.
Ja.
Look at this. Watch this. Watch that.
E. Amazing. No longer needed.
Okay.
Naja.
Okay, es ist ganz cool,
aber wär's nicht noch cooler,
wenn man einfach das exception hätte
hier weglassen können.
Oder noch besser, einfach die Klammer
nicht so irgendwie... Aber ja, okay.
Es ist ganz nice. Ja, weil man
einfach, egal welche exception,
catchen will und... Ja.
Why not?
If that's not reason enough to switch
to PHP, I don't know what to tell ya.
Okay, remember those attributes that I
told you about literally two seconds ago?
There's an attribute that will mark an
argument as sensitive and redact it from
all stack...
Coole Sache. Das finde ich nice.
Das könnten sich manch andere Sprachen auch noch abgucken.
So you don't accidentally end up logging
something you shouldn't.
Oder was sagt der? Das ist cool.
At the language level. Very cool.
Look at this switch statement. It's hideous.
It's huge. We hate it.
What we're doing is we're switching on a status code
and then in the body of every status, we're
setting a message variable.
There's gotta be a better way.
There is a better way. We can use the
match statement now and assign
the message variable to the result
of the match statement. And look, at
200, 300, we can have
multiple matches return the same
thing. This is a much more compact,
much more readable way to write
a switch statement.
Wie, Pattern Matching haben sie auch mittlerweile drinne?
Also ganz ehrlich?
Man könnte sagen, sie haben sich einfach
alles abgeguckt, was in anderen Programmierstätten nicht so gut ist.
In anderen Programmiersprachen so in den letzten
zehn Jahren gut funktioniert hat.
Aber das ist doch nicht schlimm.
Das ist doch gut. Man muss ja nicht
das Rad neu erfinden. Es hat sich bewährt
in anderen Sprachen und dementsprechend macht
es höchstwahrscheinlich in PHP auch Sinn.
Ist das einfach nur ein switch case?
Nee. Ein switch case hättest du keine
Variable am Anfang stehen.
Sondern du hättest
ein switch statement für sich.
Hier kommt ja quasi ein return-Wert
raus, der dann da
zugewiesen wird. Übrigens, weil
wir es gerade von
der Rust Syntax hatten.
Double link list in Java.
Warum ist das pain?
Weil wir es gerade von Rust hatten.
Ich habe jetzt mal ein Beispiel gerade hier nebenbei
aufgemacht. Tokio ist eines der größten
I.O. Frameworks
in Rust.
Das ist kein super ekliges Beispiel,
aber es ist
hübsches Rust
und ich finde schon an hübschem Rust sieht man,
dass es eben nicht ganz so
eindeutig ist. Guckt euch mal das hier an.
Ja.
Also,
das kann man alles noch lesen,
aber es ist nicht wirklich klar, was da
passiert, wenn man nicht der große Rust Checker
ist.
Was passiert hier, Chat?
Also ich finde, das ist
nicht unbedingt jetzt gerade so auf den ersten Blick
klar.
Das hier verstehe ich noch.
Async function
createDir, so heißt das Ding.
Alles gut. So, jetzt Variable
ok, beziehungsweise Parameter ok.
Im
sRefPath, so.
Das ist das erste, wo ich mir denke, ok,
keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass hier hinter jetzt
der Datentyp kommen muss,
von dem Parameter.
Bedeutet das hier, dass
jeder Datentyp erlaubt ist,
der dieses Interface
implementiert?
Wahrscheinlich. Ja, kann man sich dann auch noch
zusammen reimen. Ja, kommt man mit der Zeit drauf.
Dann gibt es
einen Return Wert von IO
result.
Eckige, ein
generic IO result
vom Typ
geschweifte Klammer auf, geschweifte Klammer zu.
Was auch immer es ist.
Dann haben wir typische
Rust Magic. Path as
ref to owned.
Das heißt, dass der Borrow Checker nicht
meckert beim
kompilieren.
So, dann wird
asyncify move.
Oder, oder.
Ich glaube ja,
dass dieses oder, oder, das ist
kein oder an der Stelle in Rust.
Das ist ein
so eine Art
Inline Block.
Man könnte ja auch,
keine Ahnung, wie man das
nennt in Rust.
Und am Ende kommt da noch ein Punkt
await dran.
Was auch immer, wie jetzt
genau.
Das kann man schon lesen.
Aber ich finde, man erkennt daran
schon, dass Rust,
gerade wenn es dann auch ein bisschen mehr wird,
doch schon eine Sprache ist mit viel
Komplexität drinne.
Wo auch gerne mal
so ein Quellcode-File
komplett voll sein kann mit
es springt dich gefühlt
die ganze Datei mit Sonderzeichen entgegen.
Aber wenn man jetzt hier durchguckt,
wird man sicherlich noch ein bisschen
keine Ahnung,
bisschen mehr finden.
Na gut, das sind Rust Imports, die gehen ja noch
halbwegs.
Da gibt es diese Magic-Struck-Geschichten.
Zwischendrin hast du vielleicht noch ein paar Makros oder sowas.
Und das ist halt wirklich auch schon
sehr ordentliches Rust hier.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich so diesen Text vor mir hab,
es ist schon ein bisschen
mühselig zu lesen.
Und das ist noch sehr hübsches Rust.
Ist schon teilweise ein bisschen mühselig zu lesen.
Aber das geht ja echt noch, klar hier.
Da hat sich auch einer wirklich
Mühe gegeben hier.
Na gut, genug Rust.
Was hältst du von Recruitern auf LinkedIn?
Eher Abstand oder kann man das mal machen?
Warum nicht? Wenn die ein gutes Angebot haben,
scheiß doch drauf von wo es kommt.
Sprich nix dagegen.
Die werden dir alle möglichen
Bullshit erzählen.
Du musst halt gucken, ob da was dran ist.
Die verdienen ja auch fett Geld an der Vermittlung.
Musst halt gerade dann,
wenn du dort mal vor Ort bist,
die wollen dich ja irgendwo hinvermitteln,
auf den Zahn fühlen, ob das auch alles so stimmt.
Aber warum nicht?
Wenn da ein gutes Angebot dabei ist.
Würde ich jetzt kein Problem sehen.
Denkst du, es lohnt sich momentan
Informatik zu studieren?
Klar, warum nicht?
Wenn das das ist, wo du Bock drauf hast
und was dir vorschwebt, sicher.
Dass du jetzt davon ausgehen kannst,
dass du mit einem Informatikstudium
prinzipiell mehr Geld verdienst,
als mit einer Ausbildung,
ist im Durchschnitt so.
Für dich individuell muss das allerdings nicht zutreffen.
Du kannst mit einer
Physi-Ausbildung genauso gut
Fettkohle machen in der IT,
wie als studierter Informatiker.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Leider gibt es immer noch kein gescheites Rust
für ein ESP32.
Es gab so ein paar Versuche, aber das ist, glaube ich,
nie irgendwas wirklich gut Benutzbares rausgekommen.
Was hältst du davon, als Freelancer zu arbeiten?
Hast du mal überlegt, das selbst zu machen?
Ja, das habe ich überlegt.
Aber um mal auf die Sache von vorhin zurückzukommen.
Chat, was meint ihr, warum ich das nicht gemacht habe?
Ihr werdet nicht drauf kommen.
Korrekt, weil ich zu faul bin.
Da musst du dich
um jeden Mist selber kümmern.
Mir geht das ja mit Twitch und YouTube schon auf den Sack.
Und da muss ich einmal im Jahr mein Zeug
zum Steuerberater schicken, so nach dem Motto.
Und, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das gebe ich mir nicht.
Das mache ich nicht.
Also ich kenne einige, wo sich das wirklich gelohnt hat.
Geldtechnisch.
Als Freelancer zu arbeiten.
Aber auch viele von denen,
gerade die, die ich schon ein bisschen länger kenne,
die sind auch nicht mehr als Freelancer tätig.
Kohlemäßig hat es sich gelohnt.
Aber vieles ging ihnen
wahrscheinlich zu sehr auf den Keks.
Also locker die Hälfte von denen,
die ich jetzt über die Jahre kennengelernt habe,
arbeiten mittlerweile festangestellt wieder irgendwo.
Nun ja.
So, PHP, weiter.
Ja, Pattern Matching in PHP, coole Sache.
Finde ich nice, dass das drin ist.
Es sollte eigentlich jede Sprache haben.
Schade, dass JavaScript das Ganze nicht hat.
Man kann das sicherlich
in JavaScript in irgendeiner
Art und Weise mit
Funktionen oder sowas
vielleicht ähnlich
nachbauen.
Aber es wäre cool,
wenn JavaScript sowas auch hätte.
C-Sharp hat es mittlerweile und zwar richtig gute
Implementierung, wie ich finde.
Ich habe eine Weile gebraucht, mich in C-Sharp
an die neue Switch-Syntax
zu gewöhnen.
Aber ich finde, seit der letzten C-Sharp-Version
wurde jetzt auch
dieses ArraySelector und sowas
dabei.
ArrayTeile, Selector,
Matcher dabei haben.
Das ist richtig gut.
Äh, ich bin doch nicht gut.
Wait a minute, sollte nicht alles garbage collected werden,
was keine
Reference mehr hat?
Also,
der einzige Grund,
warum ich in C-Sharp mal eine
WeakMap verwendet habe,
es gab
zwei Sachen und ich kriege
beide nicht mehr so hundertprozentig hin.
Das eine, also
es waren beides was garbage collector
mäßiges.
Ähm,
das erste war
irgendwelches WebRTC Zeug im Backend,
wo ich eine WebRTC
Session
initialisiert habe,
die
nicht ordentlich
garbage collected
wurde,
weil,
ah, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher,
weil das irgendwie eine Referenz
auf sich selbst hat oder irgendwie,
es war wir, ich krieg's nicht
mehr genau zusammen. Da muss ich
eine WeakMap verwenden.
Ah, ich weiß es wieder.
Ich weiß es wieder.
Weil ich,
weil ich sowas gemacht hab.
Ähm,
ich hoffe ich krieg das jetzt noch zusammen, wartet mal.
Weil ich sowas, nur mal kurz so als Beispiel,
weil ich sowas in der Richtung gemacht hab.
Ähm, ja,
machen wir mal ein bisschen Platz hier unten.
Ich versuch's euch mal zu zeigen.
Äh,
ich hab sowas in der Richtung gemacht.
Und zwar hab ich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, war,
keine Ahnung, blub gleich new,
so, keckel, sowas ist meine
Klasse. Dann hab ich gesagt,
keckel.callback, oder was
weiß ich hier, onload,
oder so, oder
onconnect, oder was auch immer.
Und
dadrinne hab ich
dann,
ups, dadrinne
hab ich dann, glaube ich,
Moment, ist auch falsch, was ich hier mache.
Darin hab ich dann, glaube ich,
irgendwie auf blub,
äh, keine Ahnung,
wie oder so zugegriffen. Irgendwie so
in der Richtung muss das gewesen sein. Ich krieg's nicht mal
ganz zusammen. Und
da gab's dann Probleme,
dass, dass
es nicht garbage collected werden
konnte,
in, in diesem, in diesem Umstand,
weil,
weil hier gibt's ne Referenz
auf
das, und
das hat ne Referenz auf, also,
das hat, ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob's so war, ja.
Es könnte auch irgendein Event gewesen sein. Zumindest hat es da
mit dem garbage collect nicht funktioniert.
Und da musste ich auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise
so, so ne weak map reference
Zeug verwenden, dass es funktioniert, so.
Und das andere, wo ich mal in C Sharp
eine, so,
weak map reference verwendet
hab, war
zum Debuggen vom
garbage collector selbst,
um zu gucken,
ob
ein Objekt
aufgeräumt wird,
vom garbage collector.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, es ist gar nicht so einfach
zu checken, ob ein Objekt vom garbage collector
aufgeräumt wird, weil, sobald ihr
in das Objekt reinguckt, hat's
ne Referenz und wird nicht garbage collected.
Versteht ihr, versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Also, also wenn ich jetzt sowas hier hab,
war, blub, ja,
war, war blub eins,
so, und ich hab jetzt hier im Hintergrund
irgendwas, was, äh,
checken soll,
ob das, ob das schon aufgeräumt ist. Ich weiß nicht,
task run, task run,
so, ich, ich guck jetzt hier im Hintergrund immer nach,
ob, hier,
while, true,
await, task, delay,
so, ich guck jetzt einmal in der Sekunde nach,
ob blub schon aufgeräumt
wurde, ja. Das ist das Problem,
so, sobald ich hier auf
blub zugreife,
dann hat's ja ne Referenz,
und dementsprechend wird das nie garbage collected.
Ihr, ihr versteht
das Problem wahrscheinlich, so.
Und da musste man auch irgendwie
weak reference
boah,
keine Ahnung mehr, wie, wie das
genau ging, irgendwie weak reference,
ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das muss man sogar vorher anlegen,
und dann konnte man mit ner weak reference
checken, ob denn das Objekt
noch alive ist.
Check if
gets garbage
collected,
das war echt sehr durch die,
how to tell
if an object has been garbage collected.
Here, weak reference,
genau, is alive kann man dann checken,
korrekt, genau, dafür hab ich
das mal gebraucht, für diese zwei Sachen.
Aber ansonsten, eigentlich
nie, so, und deswegen weiß ich auch nicht, wie das
PHP wahrscheinlich ähnlich
ist.
Weak map ist wie hash map,
das heißt, das ganze, was ich euch jetzt erzählt hab,
war umsonst, weil's eigentlich um was ganz anderes
geht, na gut.
Da geht's
halt um was anderes.
Ich muss mal kurz den Kram aufräumen,
sonst wundere ich mich das nächste Mal,
warum mein Kram hier nicht mehr funktioniert.
Okay, excellent.
Enums in PHP,
auch so ein Ding, wo ich mich wundere,
warum's das nicht schon länger gegeben hat,
und,
und warum braucht es da drinnen
einen case?
Wahrscheinlich nur, weil sich irgendein
language designer gedacht hat,
dass es so ein ding ist,
also,
das ist eine coole Sache, dass da case davorsteht.
Macht doch, macht doch
ernsthaft, macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass da case
davorsteht, oder?
Außer, dass man mehr schreiben muss.
Also, ich hab mir sagen lassen,
dass, weil in TypeScript,
in TypeScript gibt es ja Enums,
und ich hab mir sagen lassen,
dass selbst
in TypeScript, wo es Enums gibt,
davon abgeraten wird,
Enums zu verwenden,
und
anstatt dessen
plain JavaScript Objekte
zu verwenden.
Also,
vielleicht doch nicht so geil.
Gibt es das nicht?
Kein Enums in Go?
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Was'n des?
Du kannst Methoden zu deinen Enum-Klassen
hinzufügen, in diesem Fall.
Was?
Dann ist es aber doch kein richtiger Enum mehr, oder?
Auf der anderen Seite.
So schlecht
finde ich das gar nicht mal.
So schlecht finde ich das eigentlich gar nicht.
Gerade für sowas, ja,
wie zum Beispiel Output-Formatieren und sowas.
Warum nicht?
Ich mein,
es gibt jetzt wenig Anwendungsfelder,
wo ich mir denke,
ja, das hätte ich jetzt mal gebraucht,
auf nem Enum.
Aber ich könnte mir irgendwelche
Sonderfälle schon vorstellen,
wo das sinnvoll ist,
ja.
Auf der anderen Seite,
ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob man das in C Sharp nicht mittels
Extension-Methods
auch erledigen kann.
Ich glaube, das geht.
Ich glaube, du kannst in C Sharp Extension-Methods
auf Enums machen.
Macht man selten, aber ich glaube, das geht.
Lass uns das doch grad mal ausprobieren.
Enum
kek w enum
Oh hier, lul.
So, bester Enum überhaupt.
So, und jetzt
public
static class
extensions
Oh,
Extension-Methods aus'm Kopf, Alter.
Wie geht das nochmal hier?
public void
ja, keine Ahnung hier.
Display, nennen wir es doch mal so, wie hier.
Display
und dann macht man, glaube ich,
this kek w enum
Static muss das nicht sein, aber
das muss, das muss static sein, gell.
this enum
e
Ist das verkehrt?
Muss doch static sein.
Am public, ja.
So, und jetzt haben wir, ja,
jetzt haben wir nen enum-Extended, das funktioniert.
So, also weil hier
lul gleich
kek w enum
Oh
Display, ja klar, geht.
Man kann enums extenden, aber
ehrlich gesagt, mir fällt kein Fall
ein, wo ich das mal gemacht hab bisher.
Aber es geht.
Es geht. Insofern,
why not? In PHP gibt's ja
keine Extension-Methods.
Warum also nicht? Find ich,
find ich nicht so schlecht.
We'll add a method
that gives a user-friendly display
to each of the enums, and we're using
the match statement again, and we're just matching
against this, and all of our cases
are our enum cases.
One of the great things
about having first-class enums
is you can now use them as type hints.
So if a method is expecting
Moment, das sind nur type hints.
Also PHP ist nach wie vor
komplett dynamisch, das heißt,
ich kann da reinstecken, was ich will.
Oder gibt es irgendeinen Compiler-Flag
so nach dem Motto, äh,
das geht nicht.
Na gut, wenn das dynamisch ist,
weiß gar nicht, ob das alles
Compile-Time, Runtime wird,
das geht scheiße. Weil zur Compile-Time
kannst du das ja gar nicht alles rausbekommen dann.
In enum?
Oder deswegen zur Build-Time,
es gibt ja nur Runtime, ja, ihr habt recht.
Deswegen ist es irgendwie so zur Build-Time,
wenn du dann dein Projekt da generieren lässt,
was auch immer, dass es da vielleicht Check gibt.
Hint that enum class,
and that way PHP will validate
that the incoming argument is that
enum. Alright, here we go.
Okay.
Also zur Runtime wird das gecheckt,
ist doch auch okay.
Übrigens, was ich sehr schön finde,
dass die
eine ordentliche Schreibweise für den Typ haben.
Ich mag,
ich mag ja diese Sachen nicht, ja.
Also, es gibt so einen Trend,
in etwas neueren Sprachen,
da macht man gerne,
wo haben wir denn hier ne,
da hat man ja hier gerne dann sowas drinne,
hier, Stopping Token
ist dann sowas, also der Typ kommt dann
dahinter und sowas, oder
oder in Rust,
in Rust macht man dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
let mut
i32
blub gleich 1
und so Dinger muss man da in Rust machen.
Ne Moment, das ist dann glaube ich doppelt, ne.
Oder ist es sogar so,
in Rust, ich kann es mir gar nicht merken.
Also,
ich finde es schön, dass sie es in PHP
gemacht haben, so wie ich es
eigentlich auch erwarten würde.
Nämlich den Typ
davor und ohne Sonderzeichen
gut ist.
Auch kein Doppelpunkt dazwischen.
In Go ist das glaube ich auch so merkwürdig
mit Doppelpunkten und sowas dazwischen.
Und auch umgedreht, glaube ich.
Ja, in Go hast du doch das zuerst,
dann Doppelpunkten, dann Int.
Also, das finde ich schön, dass die sich
einig sind.
Ja, den Return-Type kann man sich jetzt streiten,
ob das dahinter soll oder da vorne.
Ich persönlich mag es, wenn er vorne steht,
bin ich einfach dran gewöhnt.
Aber das ist auch okay.
Solange es nicht so eine hässliche
C++ Syntax mit einem Pfeil dahinter ist.
Also, es kann Int oder Float sein
und es kann einen Int oder Float zurückgeben.
Wenn du mehr als zwei Nummern zusammenführen willst
und du eine variatische Funktion hast,
kannst du auch Typen dafür verwenden.
Kein Problem.
Lass uns in eine Klasse gehen.
Hier sagen wir, dass die Artikel
Ja, ist es.
Aber es verhält sich doch ein bisschen anders,
wenn du irgendwie so, sagen wir mal,
klassenweite Variablen anlegen willst,
ohne sie gleich zu initialisieren,
dann kannst du nur varplup verwenden.
Also deklarieren und initialisieren in einem.
In dem Fall macht es, glaube ich,
das gleiche in Go,
aber man braucht trotzdem manchmal
diese Kurzschreibweise hier.
Ja, es ist eigentlich fast normal,
wenn man hauptsächlich in einer Sprache unterwegs ist.
Ich finde es auch immer ein bisschen merkwürdig,
wenn ich zwischen C Sharp Backend
und JavaScript Frontend wechseln muss
und ich mich dann auch manchmal vertippe.
Wenn man immer switcht
und gleichermaßen dort was macht drinnen
und dort, dann geht das.
Aber wenn man, sagen wir mal,
95% Frontend-Sachen gerade macht
und dann mal ein bisschen was hinzufügen will,
dann verschreibst du dich auch öfters mal.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Das ist cool!
Das ist mega!
Das würde ich mir in C Sharp auch wünschen.
Ich bin nicht der Einzige.
Das wünschen sich gefühlt 50
die gesamte Weltbevölkerung,
aber Microsoft hat keinen Bock drauf.
Das wäre mega nice.
Ja, wenn das gehen würde.
Ja, kannst auch Object nehmen für alles.
Dann musst du halt innen
drinnen wieder casten.
Doch, doch, das ist in der Diskussion,
aber irgendwie kommt Microsoft nicht zu Pötte damit.
Das wäre richtig cool, wenn das geht.
Sie haben ja
ein bisschen was in die Richtung gemacht.
Core 2 C Sharp Version
mit ihren
iNumber Interfaces
und sowas,
aber das löst das Problem nicht wirklich.
Das ist blöd.
Das ist so das letzte Feature
für C Sharp,
was ich mir eine Weile wünsche,
was einfach nicht kommt.
Das wäre cool,
wenn Microsoft sich da mal
zusammenreißt und sowas auf die Reihe kriegt.
Das wäre schon mega.
Es gibt ja schon
andere Libraries,
die das in C Sharp machen.
Zum Beispiel das hier.
Da kann man schreiben
return type ist
one of user invalid name
or name taken.
Das ist schon ganz cool,
aber es wäre halt deutlich nicer,
wenn das in der Sprache
selbst
abgebildet wäre
und sei es nur,
dass es so einen Typ in der Standard Library gibt.
Das sollte eigentlich
nicht so kompliziert sein.
Und Microsoft hat sich die letzten Jahre
nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert in C Sharp,
da nur sinnvolle Features mit reinzunehmen.
Deswegen insofern
wäre cool,
wenn sowas kommt.
Es wäre natürlich noch nicer,
wenn das syntaktisch
bisschen schöner unterstützt werden würde.
Dadurch, dass es eben
in die Sprache eingebaut wird.
Weil es gar nicht wieder
das aktuelle
Proposal aussieht. Gucken wir mal.
Falls das das aktuelle ist.
Proposals.
Vor drei Jahren gibt es das schon.
Ja.
Kann das vielleicht mal...
Ja, schreib es bitte noch.
Achso, das ist für den Compiler
Syntax, ja.
Ich verstehe doch nicht mal,
was er mir damit sagen will,
ehrlich gesagt.
Enum class shape.
Es kann quasi ein Rectangle
oder ein Circle sein.
Okay, das...
Ja, ja.
Das ist so als Union-Type quasi.
Shape. Es ist ein Shape
und im Endeffekt
akzeptiert es
Rectangles und so.
Okay, da findet man vielleicht noch ein bisschen
schönere Syntax für.
Also das wäre nice, wenn...
Uah! Uah!
Wenn es sowas gäbe noch.
Also PHP, guck mal.
PHP hat das schon.
Das ist nice.
Auch, auch schick.
Ja.
What?
Ja?
Oder Trades besser gesagt.
Ja, hat TradeFoo und TradeBar.
Könnte man so sagen
in PHP dann.
Okay, jetzt wird es wirklich mild langsam.
Jetzt wird es langsam abgedreht.
Disjunctive normal form type.
And I had to learn those words for this specific.
Wie heißt das?
Disjunctive.
The input is foo and bar or it's nullable.
You can have a disjunctive normal form type.
Disjunctive normal form type.
Alles klar, Leute.
Ihr wisst, wenn ihr demnächst glänzen wollt mit eurem Proggers-Kenntnissen.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen.
Dis-chung-was-form-normal-form-type.
Disjuncted normal form type.
Bar or it's nullable.
You can have a disjunctive normal form type.
Disjunctive normal form type.
And I had to learn those words for this specific video.
You can have foo and bar or allow it to be null.
Let's look at another example.
We've been typing arguments, but you can also have typed properties.
So if you look at this class, you'll see that the public title property is of type string.
And the public date property is of type string.
Of type date time.
Now this is a little repetitive, isn't it?
We've got the two properties at the top.
We've got the two arguments in the constructor.
And then in the constructor we have to set the class level properties.
This is a little verbose.
This is how we used to have to do it until the PHP gods introduced constructor property promotion.
And now you can put the visibility in your constructor signature.
Okay.
Das soll mit einem der nächsten C-Sharp-Versionen auch kommen.
Aber.
Ich bin da kein allzu großer Fan von.
Ich finde.
Ich finde das hier gar nicht mal so übel.
Zumal es die IDE für dich macht.
Und es gab noch ein paar andere Dinger, die ich etwas doof fand.
Wie sie das in C-Sharp implementieren wollten.
Nämlich nicht auf Konstrukte.
Genau, jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Ne, so fände ich es durchaus auch in Ordnung, wenn sie es in C-Sharp gemacht hätten.
Aber in C-Sharp kommt das auf den, äh, Class, auf Classebene hier oben soll das hinkommen.
Und dann hast du das Problem, dass Records, Structs und Classes mit solchen Konstruktoren alle gleich aussehen und sich ein bisschen unterschiedlich verhalten.
Und das sollte nicht sein.
You can say public string title and it will end up as a public property on your class.
This is called constructor promotion.
I don't love that you end up with an empty.
constructor body, but I do love that it reduces all of that boilerplate.
If you want to mark a property as read-only, meaning that it can only be initialized once and then never changed, there's a keyword for that.
You can say that a property is read-only and you can do that in the constructor as well.
If your entire class is read-only...
Ja, das habe ich in .NET bzw. in C-Sharp auch nicht verstanden, warum sie dort init eingeführt haben und warum man nicht auch einfach sagen konnte, irgendwie set read-only oder sowas.
Also warum die da wieder ein eigenes Keyword...
Ja, das habe ich in .NET oder sowas.
Also warum die da wieder ein eigenes Keyword für gebraucht haben.
...you can mark the class as read-only instead of marking each individual property as read-only.
A lot of stuff has changed.
If you haven't been paying attention, you might think PHP is dead, but alas, it is not dead.
Let's talk about speed.
Every time I make a video, people are like, yeah...
Also ich würde sagen, PHP ist vollkommen okay.
Von der Geschwindigkeit her für das meiste.
...but PHP is so slow.
PHP between like 5.6 and 7 experienced a 400% performance increase.
...and then I think PHP is like...
...another 20% between 7 and 8.
So PHP is not as slow as you remember.
So if you need something like 50.000 requests per second, you should probably still not use PHP for that.
But look at me, listen to me.
When have you personally needed 50.000 requests a second?
How many users do you have?
Das Argument zählt nicht.
You have.
Es ist egal, ob du 50.000 User...
...oder, keine Ahnung, 1.000 User hast, wenn das dazu führt, dass der einzelne User einfach schneller seine Seite sieht.
Also sprich, ja, ich kann 50.000 Requests die Sekunde ab, weil jeder einzelne Request eben so performant ist, dass ich 50.000 die Sekunde schaffe.
Wenn es nur 1.000 Leute benutzen, sind die Requests für die 1.000 Leute trotzdem schneller durch.
Also insofern finde ich das nicht zu vernachlässigen.
Allerdings glaube ich, dass es in dem Fall trotzdem kein wirklich großer Negativpunkt für PHP ist, weil es wahrscheinlich in dem Bereich ist, dass es nicht ausschlaggebend ist.
Also, keine Ahnung, hast du deine Response jetzt in 5 Millisekunden oder in 4, so nach dem Motto?
Ja, ob du es in 150 oder in 50 hast.
Das ist schon wieder ein anderer Punkt.
Alles über 150 ist eh indiskutabel.
Und die Latenz über die Leitung kommt ja noch dabei.
Wenn dein Server schon 150 Millisekunden braucht, die Response zu generieren, und du hast noch 150 Millisekunden Ping, dauert es 300 Millisekunden bis ein Teil von der Dauer des Seitenladens ewig.
Da schlenkst du die Leute schon wieder runter und du verkaufst nichts.
PHP ist fast genug.
Es ist fast genug für die meisten deiner Anwendungsfälle.
Und wenn du...
Oh, aber das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Die Anfrage muss ja auch erstmal hin.
Das sind dann sogar 450 Millisekunden.
Das ist zu lang.
Ja, glaube ich eben.
Warum kriege ich eigentlich hier irgendwelches Kekommer-Zeug empfohlen?
Ja, ich fand das ein gutes Video.
Also, ich glaube ihm sofort, dass er PHP mag und dass PHP nicht mehr Kacke ist.
Ich habe letztens PHP ausprobiert.
Und das, was ich gesehen habe, davon fand ich jetzt nicht so geil.
Aber das war eher, ja, aus Sachen drumherum.
Go 1.21 Features.
Gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Ähm, sagt mir nichts.
Wobei, sind das nicht...
Sind das nicht...
Das ist keine Anwendung.
Das sind irgendwelche Struktogramme oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung, ob das bei uns benutzt wird.
Ich meine, ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Entwickler.
Ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Entwickler.
Also, ich mache sowas schon mal gar nicht.
Und ich habe es auch noch von keinem Architekt oder so bisher bei uns gesehen.
Zumindest nicht wissentlich, dass das BPMN ist.
Wie sieht denn das aus?
BP und dann was?
MN.
Oh, 2.0.
Da gibt es Weiterentwicklung von Web 5.0.
Doch, das kann durchaus sein, dass ich sowas in der Richtung schon mal gesehen habe.
Doch, doch, das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Aber ich habe schon so viele dieser Diagrammtypen gesehen.
Keine Ahnung, ob es jetzt explizit ein BP-Dingsbums gewesen ist.
Sie sehen sich ja alle ähnlich.
Ähnlich.
Wechseln ist meine Rolle vom Software-Engineer zum DevOps-Engineer innerhalb der Firma, wo ich aktuell arbeite.
Hast du irgendwelche Tipps für mich?
Ja, beschäftige dich mit Linux.
Also, je nachdem, was ihr macht.
Aber Linux-Know-how finde ich wichtig, gerade in dem Job.
Natürlich auch ein bisschen hängt es davon ab, was du machen sollst später.
Mein DevOps ist ja so ein Ding, was überall drauf gekleistert wird, gelabelt wird mittlerweile.
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was du machst.
Aber beschäftige dich mit Linux.
Es sei denn, ihr seid eine Microsoft-Windows-Only-Bude, aber da hätte ich eh keinen Bock.
Und auch mit dem, was da noch so dazugehört mit der Zeit.
Mit dem DevOps-Bereich, mit irgendwelchen Automatisierungs-Sachen für Builds oder für Deployment oder für Clown-Infrastruktur, was auch immer noch beschäftigen müssen.
Also hast du dann so Sachen, also brauchst du solides Linux-Know-how.
Wenn es um Infrastruktur geht, sowas wie Terraform.
Wenn es so wirklich klassische VMs sind, dann auch vielleicht sowas wie Ansible.
Ja, eines der gängigen Continuous-Integration-Dinger kann auch meinetwegen Jenkins sein.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum Jenkins so viel Hate immer abbekommt.
Ich mag Jenkins.
Wenn ich auch keine Jenkins-Installation mehr selbst betreiben möchte.
Also du hast jetzt im Chat gelesen, ja anscheinend, anscheinend machen das einige.
Also ich nicht.
Wenn mir einer mit Diagramm-Malen ankommt, dann suche ich immer das Weite.
Ist ja auch, ist ja auch meistens.
Das sollen irgendwelche Highly-Paid-Consultants machen.
Und mich damit in Ruhe lassen.
Ich will keine Diagramme malen.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
22.30 Uhr.
Ich ess jetzt aber nix mehr.
Früher hätte ich mir jetzt noch eine Backofen-Pizza reingeschmissen und hätte die gefressen.
Ach, ich hab euch ja das neueste Zeug gar nicht erzählt.
Ich hab ja auf Twitter gepostet, dass ich...
Moment.
Ich such's mal raus.
Äh, Max FPS.
Man kann ja so nicht mehr auf Twitter, weil es sonst rumbackt.
Twitter immer mehr suckt.
Ja, ich hab euch doch mal gezeigt, dass ich angefangen hab, wieder ein bisschen zu rennen.
Und das war, das war die...
Die...
Ah, das ist schlecht.
Das war mein zweiter, mein zweiter Tag, wo ich gerannt bin, ja.
Und ich hab jetzt seitdem jeden...
Also was heißt seitdem?
Also 14.1.
Also ich hab jetzt die Woche durch jeden zweiten Tag...
Meine Runde gedreht.
Und die letzte Runde war 6,07 Kilometer.
Das ist die, die ich jetzt in Zukunft noch weiterlaufen werd.
Und...
Jetzt hat sich das eingependelt.
Also ich hab jetzt Durchschnitt...
Durchschnitt 8...
8,23.
Für...
Also für den Kilometer im Durchschnitt.
Ich kann euch...
Wenn ich es genau...
Wenn ich es genauer misswollte, ich kann euch das mal vorlesen.
Wo ist denn Garmin-App?
Und was machst du nach der Aufwärmrunde?
Ich lauf meine 1,5-2 Stunden auch sonst noch, die ich vorher auch schon immer gelaufen bin.
Also ich mach jetzt seit Jahren schon...
Geh ich, geh ich ein bisschen hier im Umland wandern, so 1,5-2 Stunden.
Jetzt nicht super schnell, aber jetzt auch nicht getrödelt, ja.
Und...
Das mach ich nach wie vor.
Ich mach das jetzt aktuell, mach ich das so.
Morgens...
7 Uhr fang ich ja ungefähr...
Oder kurz vor 7 Uhr fang ich ja auf der Arbeit an.
Und da ist eh noch keiner da.
Dann geh ich erstmal noch 45 Minuten AFK.
Nachdem ich was gegessen hab.
Und...
Renn mal eine Runde, so 45 Minuten.
Und wenn ich wiederkomme, sind dann auch die ersten Leute schon da.
So, also.
Also, ich hatte jetzt hier, ich guck mal kurz in meinen Kalender.
Gestern.
Gestern bin ich hier running.
Gestern bin ich gerannt.
6,07 Kilometer.
Also das sieht man jetzt nicht hier, aber...
Ich kann es zum Vergleich, also ich glaub jetzt hat sich ein bisschen eingebettet.
6,07 Kilometer.
Durchschnittlich hab ich gebraucht...
8 Minuten 24 für den Kilometer.
Und ich hab 502 Kalorien verbraucht.
Es hat 51 Minuten...
51 Minuten ziemlich genau.
51 Minuten gedauert.
Durchschnittliche Herzrate 154.
Also quasi auch so wie hier.
Ja.
Und...
Was mir aufgefallen ist...
Ich werde in der zweiten Hälfte schneller.
Eigentlich hätte ich gedacht, dass ich...
Das ist umgedreht.
Du bist am Anfang ein bisschen schneller,
umso mehr angestrengt das ist.
Umso langsamer wird man eigentlich.
Ich werde in der zweiten Hälfte schneller.
Läufst du immer die gleiche...
Ich hab zwei Strecken mir jetzt ausgesucht, ja.
Ja.
Aber die sind ungefähr gleich lang.
Also das ist einmal die hier.
Die ist 5,3 Kilometer.
Die andere ist 6 Kilometer.
Ziemlich genau.
Und hier sieht man es auch.
Ich bin schneller geworden ab der Hälfte so.
Und am Ende habe ich nochmal Vollgas gegeben.
So und guck hier mal.
Man sieht es auch.
Ich bin schneller geworden.
Also erster Kilometer...
Okay erster Kilometer war auch relativ schnell.
Erster Kilometer 8 Minuten 17.
Zweiter Kilometer 9 Minuten 5.
Dritter 8 Minuten 44.
Vierter 8 Minuten 25.
8 Minuten 15.
7 Minuten 53.
Und die letzten...
Die letzten 70 Meter bin ich halt gerannt.
Das kann man jetzt nicht zurechnen.
Wie motivierst du dich?
Also aktuell motiviert mich einfach das...
Tja.
Die Sache an sich.
Also optimale Laufgeschwindigkeit...
Ich hab mich mit der Theorie da nicht großartig beschäftigt.
Optimale Laufgeschwindigkeit ist für mich aktuell das, wo ich...
Wo es mich am wenigsten nervt, dass ich laufe.
Wie soll ich das...
Wie soll ich da so viel Gedanken drüber machen,
dass ich gerade am Laufen bin.
Das ist für mich die optimale Geschwindigkeit.
Das heißt auch...
Morgen früh renne ich eine Runde.
Jeden zweiten Tag.
Also ich weiß...
Das haben auch Leute schon auf Twitter geschrieben.
Max, deine Pulsfrequenz ist viel zu hoch.
Aber ganz ehrlich...
Ich komme mir sonst vor, als würde ich übelst schleichen.
Wenn ich langsamer laufe.
Und wenn ich langsamer laufe,
habe ich jetzt auch nicht so einen krass viel niedrigeren Puls.
Für das Verhältnis,
dass ich natürlich langsamer laufe.
Und für mich ist es tatsächlich,
so in dem Dreh am angenehmsten zu laufen.
Natürlich...
Hier, zum Schluss...
Hier...
Habe ich schon mal voll angefangen los zu flitzen.
Das ist natürlich nichts,
was ich im Durchschnitt da machen kann.
Ich kann euch sagen...
Oh, wo ist meine Uhr?
Ah, die Uhr ist im...
Die Uhr ist im Bad.
Kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken. Ja...
Den Blutpuls habe ich irgendwie...
70...
70 oder sowas.
Ja...
Und Blutdruck ist eigentlich manchmal
sogar schon ein bisschen niedrig.
Ich hatte letztens...
Habe ich...
Ich glaube...
100...
110 zu...
70 oder sowas.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar schon
ein bisschen zu niedrig, der Blutdruck.
Aber das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Dann gibt es wenigstens keinen Herzinfarkt
und keinen Schlaganfall.
Ja, denke ich auch,
dass umso geübter ich werde,
umso besser wird es.
Also, Blutdruck ist eigentlich
vielleicht schon ein bisschen zu wenig.
Das liegt aber auch daran,
dass...
Also, ich nehme ja seit ein paar Jahren...
Also, ihr müsst wissen dazu,
Leute, die öfters im Stream sind,
die wissen das ja.
Ich habe...
Also, in der Corona-Zeit habe ich...
Also, viele Leute haben während Corona zugenommen.
Ich habe ungefähr 18 Kilo abgenommen.
Aber davor habe ich
halt viel weniger mich bewegt.
Da bin ich auch viel seltener
meine Strecken wandern
gegangen und sowas.
Und da hatte ich halt schon ein bisschen Blutdruckprobleme
und seitdem habe ich...
Ich weiß nicht, wie es genau heißt.
Nämlich die Minimaldosis
von so...
von Blutdruckmedikamenten.
Also, das ist quasi
eine Viertelpille.
Ist quasi nix, so gut wie nix drin.
Aber man hat es direkt gemerkt,
es ist runtergegangen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Es ist...
Gibt es denn da noch...
Irgendwie ist es Satan, sonst was.
Das ist das, was ein bisschen die Blutgefäße
erweitert und deswegen der Blutdruck runtergeht.
Also, wahrscheinlich könnte man auch...
Wenn...
Wenn sie es legalisieren würden,
dass man Cannabis raucht, könnte man wahrscheinlich
Cannabis rauchen, ja.
Anstatt irgendwelche Pillen einzuschmeißen.
So, zumindest...
Ich nehme das jetzt schon so
eine ganze Weile. Seitdem ist der Blutdruck
auch immer wirklich okay gewesen.
Nicht viel zu niedrig, aber auch nicht so,
sondern okay. Aber seitdem ich
18 Kilo abgenommen habe,
mich regelmäßig
1,5-2 Stunden am Tag bewege,
plus jetzt noch angefangen
habe zusätzlich noch meine
45-50 Minuten
alle zwei Tage zu rennen,
habe ich halt den Eindruck,
ich könnte so langsam, aber sicher
auch mal wieder aufhören, den Scheiß zu nehmen.
Weil mein Blutdruck
ist eigentlich fast schon ein bisschen
zu niedrig mittlerweile.
Also, vielleicht sollte ich mal wieder
zum Doktor gehen und sagen,
lass doch mal wieder so einen
Langzeit-Blutdruck-Dings
Aber da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist so ätzend. Musstet ihr das mal machen?
Musstet ihr mal so
einen Langzeit-Blutdruck-Test machen
und irgendwie über 24 Stunden,
48 Stunden Blutdruck?
Das ist mega, mega nervig.
Ihr kriegt da so ein Ding, was alle 15 Minuten
oder halbe Stunde oder so
anfängt sich aufzupumpen
und Blutdruck zu messen
und dann, wenn du nachts pennen willst,
Alter, vergiss es.
Das ist mega für den Arsch.
Du willst pennen und auf einmal fängt es an
Blutdruck
So ätzend, Mann.
Das will ich nicht mehr machen.
Das will ich nicht machen.
Da muss es halt so timen,
dass es gerade zwischen,
dass die Zeit zwischen den
Messzyklen dafür ausreicht.
Ab 22 Uhr
misst das, glaube ich, auch nur noch
alle halbe Stunde oder so.
Musst halt sputen.
Das ist richtig nervig.
Das ist, also,
24 Stunden, 48 Stunden,
manche machen das ja eine Woche oder so.
Also, ja, sowas
kenne ich ja auch. Sowas habe ich auch irgendwann mal gemacht.
Aber für Blutdruck hast du so ein Blutdruckmessgerät
mit
neben dich musst du das stellen.
Das ist richtig eklig.
Nervig halt vor allem.
Theoretisch sollte ich das mal wieder machen.
Da müsste ich ja wahrscheinlich auch keine Pillen mehr nehmen.
Aber ich meine, klar, ganz ehrlich,
wer hätte damit auch rechnen können?
Ordentlich abgenommen
und mehr bewegen.
Wer hätte nur denken können, dass man dadurch einen besseren Blutdruck kriegt?
Ist ja nicht so, als hätte man's
wissen können oder so.
Aber so ist das halt.
Vieles weiß man im Vorfeld schon.
Aber es ist immer noch ein Schritt
von, ich weiß, dass es
so ist und ich weiß, dass es nicht gut ist
zu, ich mach's jetzt auch.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Jeder weiß, dass es schlecht ist, wenn man
zu fett ist und sich zu wenig bewegt und
ungesunde Sachen frisst und so.
Ich weiß auch, dass Rauchen ungesund ist.
Ja?
Aber der Schritt von zu wissen
und daraus dann auch was abzuleiten und zu machen,
das ist halt der schwerste oftmals.
Als erstes musst du es erst mal erkennen.
Aber ich glaube, so grundlegende
Sachen haben viele schon erkannt.
Aber du musst es dann halt auch machen.
Und das ist echt nicht so ohne.
ImmutableBite, danke für den Sub.
Und hätte mir das vor,
keine Ahnung, 10 Jahren,
jemand gesagt, hätte gesagt, Max, guck mal hier,
das ist ungesund und mach doch mal hier.
Verpiss dich, geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
Ich will 24-7 Kreiselclient vom
Rechner machen, ich will nicht, will nicht raus.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich jetzt
lieber rausgehe unter Leute oder so.
Aber wenn ich
nicht täglich meine Runde
mache, meine
eineinhalb, zwei Stunden, ich sag das absichtlich
so vage, weil das je nach Runde ist.
Heute war, ich hab meine Uhr nicht da.
Also heute war die Wanderrunde, kann ich euch sagen,
war,
ich hab da jetzt hier meinen Fitness-Tracker,
eineinhalb Stunden, eine
Stunde, 32,
28 war das heute.
Das war aber keine Runde,
wo ich joggen war, sondern wirklich nur
wandern, Berg, 240
Meter hoch, 240
Meter runter.
Und da hatte ich auch nur
einen durchschnittlichen Puls
von 109.
Und das mache ich jetzt schon eine Weile.
Jeden Tag, aber wirklich jeden
Tag, jeden Tag. Ausnahme
ab und zu mal sonntags nicht.
Aber ansonsten jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag eineinhalb, zwei Stunden wandern gehen.
Hier so im Gelände drumherum.
Und jetzt zusätzlich noch alle zwei Tage eine Runde
rennen. Morgen früh ist es wieder soweit.
Jep.
Jep, Glock.
Ne, das ist runtergegangen.
Ich glaub, da wird's nichts mehr tun.
Wie gesagt, aktuell motiviert mich
einfach nur die Sache an sich.
Also das mit dem Wandern auf jeden Fall ist
einzig und allein die Sache
an sich.
Weil mir fehlt jetzt auch richtig
am Tag was, wenn ich keine eineinhalb Stunden
mal ein bisschen durch den Wald oder übers
Feld oder so gelaufen bin.
Aktuell jeden zweiten Tag eine Runde
joggen gehen, das motiviert
mich tatsächlich auch noch
noch die Sache
an sich. Mir macht das
tatsächlich Spaß, auch wenn's
mega anstrengend ist.
Vielleicht lässt das
nach mit der Zeit. Also
eine Sache, die mich jetzt beispielsweise schon extrem
motiviert hat ist, als ich
angefangen habe. Mein erster Test
waren glaube ich 3,1 Kilometer.
So weit
bin ich die letzten 15 Jahre am Stück
gerannt. Und da
hatte ich übelst Muskelkater, aber richtig
krass Muskelkater den Tag danach.
Paar Tage davor bin ich
noch ein bisschen kürzer gelaufen, da hatte ich
Muskelkater in den Armen. Allein schon
müsste ich mal vorstellen, ich hatte Muskelkater
in den Armen und Schultern
nur vom Bewegen der Arme
beim Rennen. Also so
wenig wurden die benutzt, um sich da
renntechnisch zu bewegen. In den Armen.
Nicht in den Beinen, in den Armen.
So, danach hab ich
3,1 Kilometer mal getestet,
wie gut das funktioniert.
Und das
ging erstaunlich gut, nur dass ich
mega Muskelkater in den Beinen, in den Waren, in den
Oberschenkeln hatte. Und
jetzt ist es sogar so, und das ist das, was mich
auch echt schon ein bisschen motiviert hat.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab mir da auch so eine
Magnesiumpille noch eingeschmissen, dass es
wieder schneller weggeht. Und jetzt,
wo ich gestern gerannt bin,
ich hab heute nichts mehr.
Ich hab nicht, also ich hab keinen
Muskelkater in den Beinen. Ich hab heute
gemerkt, beim Berg hoch,
Berg runter wandern, hab ich schon
gemerkt, dass so die Beine ein bisschen, sagen wir mal,
bisschen angestrengter, erschöpfter
sind, weil ich gestern da meine
50 Minuten gerannt bin.
Das hab ich heute schon gemerkt
noch, aber es
ging. Ja, und ich denke mal, morgen ist das dann wieder
weg und dann kann ich wieder eine Runde rennen.
Aber ansonsten, das geht
erstaunlich gut und Muskelkater ist
jetzt auch keiner mehr da.
Da sieht man mal, wie schnell das geht,
wenn man es einfach mal macht, ja.
Aber ob ich das jetzt auf lange Sicht
durchhalte, mal gucken, mal gucken.
Also, solange mich die Sache an
sich motiviert, ist ja gut.
Da gibt's keine Frage, da
hab ich ja sogar Bock, morgens drauf
dann, da eine Runde zu rennen.
Also, die 1,5-2
Stunden über, über
die Hügel hier im Umland
täglich laufen, das mach ich
schon länger.
Das mach ich schon seit vor Corona.
Seit Corona, aber so wirklich
regelmäßig. Seit Corona mach ich das echt
jeden Tag, mindestens 1,5 Stunden.
Und das, ich mein,
hat schon seinen Grund, warum ich da 18 Kilo
in der Zeit abgenommen hab, wo andere Leute in Corona
18 Kilo draufgekriegt haben.
Und das, die
Runde Joggen hier, das mach ich jetzt
erst seit ungefähr einer Woche.
Ja, 3 Stunden gar so krass
ist ja ruhig noch nicht. Wobei man
sagen muss, die haben das, ich hab mir so eine Garmin
Fitness-Tracker-Uhr gekauft.
Ist schon sehr praktisch, ja.
Gerade weil du immer deinen Puls, Pulsschlag
Herzfrequenz hast, auch
ohne Pulsgurt, die misst das wirklich
ganz gut, am Handgelenk auch.
Und weil du halt auch
richtig schön siehst, wie schnell du gerade bist
für einen Kilometer und sowas. Das ist
mega nice, damit zu laufen. Da kannst
du, kannst, also sonst hatte ich halt immer
das Problem, ich bin viel zu schnell gelaufen,
weil es mir sonst zu lahm vorkam.
Aber wenn ich jetzt da drauf gucke
und sehe schon, ich hab nach dem Losrennen
einen Puls von 160,
denke ich mir, okay, das kannst du nicht die ganze
Runde so machen.
Mach mal ein bisschen langsam.
Und dann sieht man so, dass es sich halt so
ungefähr auf 8.30 bis 9 Minuten
einpendelt, wenn ich anfange
den Kilometer und dann geht's halt runter
so auf 8.15, 8.20
so. So, das ist
dann im Endeffekt im Durchschnitt
8.24, 8 Minuten 24
für den Kilometer sind.
Kannst du dadurch besser schlafen?
Ah, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Ich würde schon sagen, ja.
Ich würde schon sagen, ja,
aber es ist jetzt kein Riesenunterschied.
Ich konnte eigentlich schon,
also, ich hab immer
so Phasen, was das angeht. In der Regel
kann ich eigentlich ganz gut pennen.
Und
dann halt auch schnell, so
was weiß ich, wenn die Katze nachts
irgendwie mal an der Tür kratzt, weil sie rein will,
dann denke ich mir, okay, guter Zeitpunkt
jetzt mal aufs Klo zu gehen, dann gehe ich
aufs Klo, gehe ins Bett und fünf Minuten später penne ich wieder.
So nach dem Motto, ja.
Aber ich hab auch so, ich hab auch
Phasen, da kann ich
nicht gut schlafen. Jetzt mal unabhängig davon, es ist
zu warm im Schlafzimmer und es ist Sommer
und so, ja, das ist klar. Aber das liegt
glaube ich daran,
dass ich mir was doofes angewöhnt
hab, nämlich, dass ich nur noch
mit Smartphone eingeschaltet
penne. Also ich mach immer
irgendeinen Stream an oder irgendwelche
YouTube Lists oder
sowas. Ich hab dann zwar schon
Videos laufen, die
wo keiner rumschreit, ja.
Ich guck mir jetzt nicht irgendwelche
abgetretenen Let's Player an, die
alle furzlang super funny rumschreien
müssen, weil nur wenn er laut
schreit, ist das lustig. Ich guck
mir dann schon irgendwelche Sachen an, wo ich gut bei
abschalten kann, aber
ich glaube, es ist keine so
gute Idee, mich da, dass ich
mich da dran gewöhnt habe, dass ich nur
noch gescheit pennen kann,
wenn ich ein,
wenn irgendwas im Hintergrund dudelt.
Weil das Problem ist, das hört sich jetzt ja eigentlich gut an,
du kannst pennen, wenn was im Hintergrund
läuft. Naja, ich würde aber
sagen, dass man trotzdem schlechter
schläft. Also ich kann zwar nur
noch gescheit pennen, wenn was im Hintergrund läuft,
aber ich glaube, man schläft insgesamt trotzdem
schlechter, wenn was im Hintergrund läuft,
als wenn einfach Schicht
im Schacht Ruhe ist
und man so pennen kann. Aber ich hab mich da
so dran gewöhnt mittlerweile, weil ich halt immer
abends im
Bett noch ein bisschen Twitch gucke oder
irgendwelche YouTube Sachen oder irgendwelche YouTube Playlists
einmal
ich kann nicht mehr pennen so und das ist halt
das ist halt echt so ein bisschen klein Problem,
was ich hab in der Richtung.
ASMR zum Einschlafen beste
Ich guck die ein oder anderen
ASMR-Videos tatsächlich aber ganz
gerne, auch hier vorm Rechner,
aber ich mag
das nicht
im Bett auf dem Handy
zum Pennen.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist merkwürdig.
Wenn ich mir die Sachen anhöre,
ne,
Irrlicking Mouth Sounds, das ist nicht
so unbedingt meins.
Also, wenn ich mir die Sachen hier vorm
Rechner anhöre oder so, da werde ich übelst
müde und könnte gleich pennen gehen, so
nach dem Motto. Aber im Bett
zum Einschlafen mag ich keine ASMR-Videos,
weil ich bei denen immer
nicht weiß,
wann sie fertig sind. Klingt blöd,
weil die sind ja
oftmals mega leise und dann
knistert mal wieder was, dann sagt mal
wieder einer was leise, dann ist mal wieder eine halbe
Minute, wo du das Gefühl hast, da kommt
nix und durch dieses
es ist eine halbe Minute nix zu
hören und dann hört man wieder
leise was, das macht mich dann wieder
wach. Deswegen gucke ich viel
lieber zum
zum Pennen
irgendwelche Themen,
die mich am Rande interessieren,
die ich anfangen kann zu
gucken, während ich noch wach bin
und dann dabei einschlafe. Ich gucke beispielsweise
mega gerne
solche Videos irgendwie
ähm
was ich
das größte schwarze Loch
im Universum wurde
entdeckt oder
oder
das Alter des Universums
solche Sachen gucke ich gerne, kann man
wunderbar im Hintergrund laufen lassen.
Gibt's ja auch jede
Menge Channels, die das alles
ohne rumzuschreien machen.
Das gucke ich gerne.
Ich gucke
sehr gerne irgendwelche
Fantasy-Lore-Videos zum
einschlafen.
Sei es World of Warcraft-Lore,
obwohl mich das überhaupt nicht interessiert, spiele ich nicht.
Dungeons & Dragons-Lore-Videos,
obwohl mich Lores in Game auch normal
nicht großartig interessiert,
aber das ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen wie
wie so Gute-Nacht-Geschichten-mäßig, ja?
Da höre ich mir irgendein Video an, so
Hintergrundgeschichte
von irgendeinem Fantasy-Character
und sowas.
Juckt mich null, aber
ist wunderbar zum Abschalten.
Und es labert einer immer
recht monoton die ganze Zeit, das ist
wobei ich gut pennen kann.
Welche Gaming-Lore hast du? Ich habe eine Forerunner...
Ich glaube 245?
Ja.
Ich glaube... Ah Gott!
Da, da, da, hier, da.
Das sieht...
Das sieht danach aus, ja.
Ja.
Das ist die, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe die hier gerade nicht liegen, aber das ist die.
Die gucke ich tatsächlich
gerne, aber
die kann ich nicht zum Einschlafen
gucken, weil da wird dann auch manchmal
ein bisschen Krach gemacht.
Die lässt sich super mit meiner Wander-App
koppeln, da kann ich
die Kurse werden gesynct und die Touren
werden zurück in die Wander-App gesynct.
Eigentlich richtig, richtig nice.
Also die Uhr hat
und der eigentliche Grund, warum
ich mir die Uhr gekauft habe, war
die Navigationsfunktion.
Ich habe mir die Uhr gar nicht
als Motivation gekauft.
Gab es jetzt eigentlich
das Update?
Achso, ja, die ist immer noch
kacke.
Ich habe mir die Uhr gar nicht gekauft, weil ich
mir gedacht habe, super Motivation
um noch ein bisschen mehr Sport zu machen.
Was es jetzt im Endeffekt ist, aber
Komoot als Wander-App.
Aber der Grund,
warum ich mir die gekauft habe ist,
weil ich mir gedacht habe,
das ist eine super Sache zur
Navigation, weil
ich laufe auch mal ganz gerne,
ich plane dann in der Wander-App
irgendeine Runde und
ich laufe auch mal ganz gerne Runden, wo ich halt noch nicht
100 Mal gelaufen bin.
Und eine Sache, die mich halt immer mega
nervt ist, wenn du irgendwo
langläufst, wo du dir nicht ganz sicher bist,
wo es lang geht, wenn du dann
läufst, hast
links und rechts noch deine
Walking-Wanderstöcke, wobei
ich habe so Walking-Stöcke,
ich habe nicht so diese
Tracking-Stöcke, wie man das kennt,
sondern solche Nordic-Walking-Stöcke.
Wenn du links und rechts so einen Stock
hast und dann aufs Handy
gucken musst, wenn du
wissen willst, ob du noch auf dem richtigen Weg
bist, ist doof.
Die Wander-App, die sagt zwar an,
so jetzt hier in 300 Meter rechts,
aber auch nicht immer und nicht immer
ganz klar, was gemeint ist. Und du musst dann
öfters mal, während du gerade am
Wandern bist, gucken, dass du richtig bist, Handy
rausholen, Bildschirm anmachen,
auf die Wander-App gucken, das ist nervig.
Das war der eigentliche Grund, warum ich mir die Uhr gekauft
habe, weil ich mir dort
den Weg anzeigen lassen kann.
Zwar ohne Karten, ohne alles,
aber es reicht ja. Die Uhr hat GPS
und du siehst halt genau, ob du auf dem roten Weg noch
bist oder nicht. Und
seitdem ich mir die
gekauft habe, finde ich das
auch sehr motivierend, Stats über
das eigene, die eigenen
Aktivitäten zu sehen. Deswegen finde ich,
ist das wirklich großer
Motivationsfaktor nochmal zusätzlich, wenn
man das ordentlich tracken kann.
Das Gute an Wander-Apps sind, im Vergleich zu
Google Maps, gar nicht so sehr das
wirklich viel bessere Kartenmaterial
oder so. Wahrscheinlich ist es eh mehr oder
weniger das Gleiche.
Die Routenplanung
zu wandern ist oftmals besser, aber
du hast halt
viele Möglichkeiten zu gucken,
okay, was sagen die Leute über
diese Strecke und sowas. Das ist halt sehr praktisch.
Also, was
liegt auf der Strecke, was man sich gerne
angucken
sollte und so.
Das ist praktisch, ja.
Also, ich plane die Routen oftmals
anhand der
Punkte, die die anderen auf der Map eingetragen
haben und da guckst du rein und denkst, oh, sieht nett aus,
da können wir lang laufen. Außerdem weißt du
dann halt auch genau, wie lang ist
das und wie lange braucht man zu Fuß und so.
Also, gerade zu Fuß, die Routenplanung von Google Maps
ist nicht so geil. So durch den Wald
und so. Wie lang hält der Akku
von der Uhr? Ich würde
sagen, so
vier, fünf
Tage,
fünf Tage, also
auf jeden Fall länger als
bei den fetten Smartwatches,
die es so gibt, die einen Tag halten.
Also, ich glaube offiziell sagen sie sieben Tage,
aber das habe ich noch nicht
ausprobiert.
Also, ich habe sie bisher eigentlich immer nach zwei
Tagen aufgeladen, aber nicht, weil sie
leer war, da war es irgendwie auf 70 Prozent oder so,
sondern einfach, weil sie halt neben dem
USB-Anschluss lag.
So, Leute,
jetzt gehe ich pennen.
Wir sehen uns morgen früh, 8.30 Uhr oder
9 Uhr, so in dem Dreh,
zum Aufwachen streamen und dann bin ich
vorher schon mal eine Runde gerannt.
Dann kann ich euch berichten, wie es lief.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.